hey everybody Dr Joe here little tip for
you to change is to be greater than your
environment that means be greater than
the conditions in your life to be
greater than the circumstances in your
world and every great person in history
knew this that means you have to be
defined by a vision of the future
instead of the memories of the past to
change means be greater than your body
those unconscious habits and behaviors
and choices that you've made over and
over again so many times that the body
becomes the Mind emotions that are
connected to past experiences keep you
anchored emotionally to the past and if
those emotions are driving your thoughts
and those thoughts are creating the same
emotions then your body has become the
mind which means that in order for you
to change you're going to have to get
greater than those emotional reactions
habits and hardwired attitudes that keep
you running unconscious programs and to
change then is to be greater than time
if you're waking up every single day and
making the same choices and
demonstrating the same behaviors and
creating the same experiences and you do
that over and over again in it makes
sense that your past is going to look a
lot like your future and your future
will be more of your past finding The
Sweet Spot of the generous present
moment existing in that place where
you're no longer trying to predict the
future based on the past means you're in
the unknown and when you're in that
place call the Eternal present moment
that's where all possibilities exist
give it a try
when I make these videos
big first business I quit on my business
partner I was making 300 bucks a month
and I didn't have the motivation to keep
going and the thing that got me through
was studying the stories of
entrepreneurs who've had massive success
and I hope that in sharing these stories
with you you find a motivation to keep
going and if I'm being honest I still
need the source for myself today too so
today let's learn from one of the best
Dr Joe dispenza and get some incredible
motivation enjoy
your personality is made up of how you
think
how you act and how you feel so the
present personality who's listening to
this podcast has created the present
personal reality called their life which
means then if you want to change your
life you want to create a new person in
reality you're gonna have to change your
personality you're going to have to
change because nothing changes in your
life until you change so what is the
understanding of change that we've spent
over 10 years studying a way to explain
what change is because
if you think 60 to 70 000 thoughts or
however many thoughts in one day and
ninety percent of those thoughts are the
same thoughts as the day before you're
in trouble because the same thoughts
will lead to the same choices the same
choices will lead to the same behaviors
the same behaviors create the same
experiences and the same experiences
produce those very same emotions and
those same emotions influence our same
thoughts and our biology our neural
circuitry our neurochemistry our
hormones or gene expression
our immune to everything stays the same
because we're the same so it has
traditionally taken crisis or trauma or
loss for someone to make up their mind
to change so the moment we decide to
change okay I want to create a new
personal reality a new life
I got to change my personality well this
concept called metacognition we have
four brain function you know the seat of
our conscience our frontal lobe allows
us to think about what we're thinking
about to notice how we're behaving and
and to become aware of how we're feeling
and
the the repetition of thinking acting
and feeling in the same way causes our
brain to become hardwired into very
specific neural patterns right so that
that firing and wiring over time cause
us causes us to be happen so
automatically that we're unconscious
of our conscious self so the moment we
become conscious of those thoughts the
moment we become aware of those
behaviors the moments we notice those
feelings we're no longer the program in
fact where the Consciousness observing
the program and that's the first step to
change look people can create all kinds
of wealth and they can create all kinds
of abundance they can have the cars the
homes and everything but if they can't
be present right to enjoy them I've sat
with billionaires and they've looked me
in the eye and said we're all miserable
we're all miserable and and and and and
and and so then at what point do you
have to wait uh to change does it have
to be that lowest point or or or can you
learn and change in a state of joy and
inspiration instead of instead of pain
and suffering and that that becomes the
art right so then
to change then is to be greater than the
habituations the drives and the emotions
that have been conditioned in the body
to change is to be greater than the
conditions in our environment that every
person every object everything in our
life has a neurological Network
associated with them they're knowns
because we've experienced them and we
have an emotion associated with them so
you if you're not being defined by a
vision of the future you're left with
the memories of the past and you see
your ex and you're going to see your ex
through the memory of your past
neurologically and it's going to elicit
an emotional response and you're
thinking of feeling equal to your
environment your life's not going to
change so then the next question is how
could I overcome that condition that
with my ex can I actually forgive could
I actually open my heart can I actually
the reason we do this is because the
stronger the emotion we feel towards
someone or something in our life the
more we pay attention to them and where
we place our attention is where we place
our energy and so then we're giving our
power away to that person or
circumstance that's vital life force you
could use to change the person who's
sitting in the meditation
and they want to quit this is they're
thinking they're doing their meditation
wrong I want to tell you you're doing it
right that's the defining moment right
and you lower the volume to that emotion
I guarantee you'll take your attention
off that person and sooner or later when
the body finally settles down and you
get Beyond it you're going to take your
power back and that's building your own
electromagnetic field now you have
energy to heal now you have energy great
we've measured this now you have energy
for for creation we don't see things how
they are we see things how we are and so
though I I don't like to use the word
visualization because I think it's been
okay it's been overused I like to use
the word mental rehearsal I don't care
if you're a virtuoso a musician
I don't care if you are a performer or
an actor I don't care if you're a dancer
or an athlete everybody does this who's
engaged in getting better at whatever
they do they will rehearse the course
now or the re rehearse the ACT enough
times that the once they can concept the
whole thing to its completion
and they get out of that think box then
the think box is so important because we
have to
review our act we have to repeat it
enough times and the act of mental
rehearsal really installs the
neurological Hardware in your brain it
primes the brain free so you have
circuits to use now mental rehearsal
also changes the body you can take a
group of men
and have them imagine or rehearse doing
bicep curls for an hour a day for two
weeks and add an emotional component
called stronger harder more intense and
for one hour they practice in their mind
doing those those curls at the end of
two weeks there's a 13.5 increase in
muscle strength they never lifted weight
their bodies changing by thought alone
so the person who's priming their brain
and body through rehearsal
when they get in their play box there's
no thinking they're just doing there's
just the act in fact the thought of what
they're doing becomes the experience
they get lost in the act and they're
analytical facilities they're they're
analytical mind is out of the way and
they can they can sustain a state where
nothing in their environment is going to
move them from the state they're in the
feeling of what it would feel like to
play well and they hold on to that
feeling and when the conditions get
tense they actually do something
different they self-regulate and they
actually crave this moment of
performance to be able to produce an
outcome and so there's no mysticism to
this it's just what people do when they
get really into something is that we
rehearse all the time so but people
understand if you take a group of people
that never played the piano before and
you teach them one-handed scales them
chords and they come in practice for two
hours a day for five days at the end of
five days if you do a brain scan and
before and after they'll grow circuits
on the opposite side of the brain no
magic there you learn something new
learning's making new connections get
your body involved you get some
instruction you have an experience
experience enriches the circuits repeat
it over and over again fire and wire and
pay attention and stay present you'll
assemble new neurological circuitry
take another group of people have them
close their eyes and actually have them
mentally rehearse playing the scales and
chords for two hours a day for five days
scan their brain before and after in the
end of five days their brain will look
like they've been playing the piano for
five days but they never lifted a finger
the brain literally changed through the
rehearsal okay so now take the person
and put them in front of a piano never
played the piano before and they could
actually play those scales and chords
like the people who are actually
physically demonstrating it so what does
that have to do for the single mother of
three children what does that have to do
with the person
who's trying to heal a health condition
it's not enough to just have a good
meditation and get up and spend the rest
of your day reacting and responding to
the conditions in your life that's one
hour of living and conditioning your
body and brain into the future against
15 hours of you and responding
emotionally from your past so we got to
rehearse okay how am I going to be in
this situation how am I going to change
what would love do today what would
greatness look like it's the it's those
frontal lobe questions that actually
begins to install the circuitry and we
all do it naturally the only time we
don't do it is when we're living in
stress and we're living in survival why
because it's not a time to create it's
not a time to learn it's not a time to
go inward it's not and not a time to
Dream It's a time to run fight and hide
and if you're spending the majority of
your time in the arousal of those stress
hormones
than most people then their senses
become heightened they narrow their
focus and now they're engaged in doing
anything they can relying on something
outside of them to take away that
feeling so if people begin to understand
that they actually can change and
there's a they understand a formula to
do it and they practice that formula and
they rehearse it both by mentally
rehearsing it and actually participating
in it the effects should be in the
experiment that something should change
either in your body or in your life and
that's why we do it so when you see the
changes or the synchronicities or the
coincidences or the opportunities
starting to show up in your life you're
going to pay attention to what you did
and you're going to do it again and many
people who have chronic health
conditions that just get Beyond those
thoughts and those habits and those
emotions that keep them as that same
personality and begin to think act and
feel differently
notice dramatic changes in their in
their health and in their biology and we
have the data to suggest that people who
do this for seven days their body looks
like genetically and biologically
they're in a different life their body
is no longer responding in the same way
and they're no longer victims to their
environment because they can
self-regulate there tends to be a
greater resistance
uh to anything in their environment even
on a microscopic level I have a couple
theories about relationships that I
think are really important and I I use
the same exact principles with my life
first of all I will never work in a
relationship and I don't think anybody
should work in a relationship I think if
you're working in a relationship
something is not clicking something is
not right
but if you bring your best
and the person that you're with brings
their best
and you celebrate your life together
then there's there's constructive
interference there's growth there's
energy
if you're not at your best and you show
up more than likely you're going to pick
someone or something apart and it's
better that you remove yourself
for a period of time and get back into
your heart and present yourself at your
best and so if you're not there and you
need a mirror or a reflection
then it's good to ask am I missing
something am I not seeing myself in some
way and then there's a healthy
conversation when you invited
but if you're not invited to contribute
your opinion then it's better off that
you don't right so people always say I
want a loving relationship but what they
really want is happiness really so we we
do these meditations to create love in
our lives and and it could be love in uh
familiar relationships with your
siblings it could be with your parents
it could be with your friends or it
could be with a significant other
and so
if
thoughts are the electrical charge in
the quantum field
and feelings are the magnetic charge in
the quantum field and how you think and
how you feel broadcast an
electromagnetic signature that
influences every single atom in your
life the thought sends the signal out
and the feeling is the magnetic field
that draws the event back to you right
so if you're not in a place where you're
in love with life
or in love with yourself or practicing
diminishing your emotional reactions to
certain people or conditions in your
life and you're living in anger or
hostility or judgment or fear and you
want a loving relationship
there is no magnetic field for you to
draw that to you and in fact if you say
to me well it's that person or that
circumstance that's caused me to feel
this way then I would say
you mean that person or that
circumstance is controlling the way you
feel and the way you think and anything
that controls the way we feel and the
way we think we are victims too right so
most people are unconsciously responding
to the conditions in their environment
experiencing emotions that are derived
from the hormones of stress those
emotions cause us to feel separate from
our dreams they heighten our senses so
if we can't see them it doesn't exist
the threat or the danger puts us in
emergency mode and we can think
positively about the relationship we
want we could send the signal out into
the field we could have pictures we
could have we could remind ourselves of
what it is but if you're not drawing the
experience back to you because your
response to the environment
is actually weakening your organism it's
weakening your response is actually
weakening the body
then you will be as a victim more
vulnerable to the conditions in your
environment whether they're large or
small and I'm talking about
microorganisms as well so if you wanted
a true relationship where it was
fundamentally based on this concept
called love now let's talk about that
because we practice this a lot in the
work that we do
if you could truly begin to practice
trading those survival emotions every
day
for elevated emotions and you practiced
opening your heart
it's it's a it's a skill that has to
take place where you move out of
survival I think the first thing is to
learn every time you learn you make new
Connections in your brain and learning
is making those connections and I was
joking with my staff this week I said
nobody reads anymore nobody reads nobody
reads anything learn information why
because we found out
that in our events if you can be present
and not look at your cell phone or not
talk about your past but be present with
the content and I can combine quantum
physics with Neuroscience with
neuroendocrinology with psychonur
Immunology Mind Body Connection
epigenetics electromagnetism you can
really get it like you can give me the
nod and then I say okay you I look at an
audience of 1500 600 people okay well
turn to the person next to you and teach
it back to them if you can't explain
that um
it's not wired in your brain and you'll
doubt that it's possible and you'll do
something differently okay if you can
explain it then you're causing your
brain to Fire and new sequences and new
patterns and new combinations whenever
you make your brain work differently
you're changing your mind why
because mind is the brain in action so
you keep reminding yourself in this now
this it's easier to forget this than
remember it you know it takes practice
it really you can't get it in one bite
it's a learning process right so now
you're installing the neurological
Hardware in your brain in preparation
for the experience so knowledge is the
precursor to the experience right
without the knowledge and the
information it's conjecturous right so
the more you understand the what in the
terms of what you're doing and the why
you're doing it the application the
Practical aspect the how becomes
exciting like oh I'm going to get it as
an example you can take someone and
throw them in an ice bath
we have no knowledge of ice but what
that can do and then because I have no
knowledge the ice path is actually going
to is going to cost them harm right
right you take that person you can teach
them a few things and put them in an ice
bath and actually be instrumental I'll
actually gain value from it well the
prefrontal cortex the one that said now
you got to make this you got to make
this valuable you can take a person
and you can you can put them in an
environment and they can perceive the
environment as a problem and you can
measure their autonomic response and
it'll weaken their autonomic response
you can take that person and have them
perceive it as a challenge and it'll
actually strengthen their autonomic
response okay so now what's the what's
what's the reason behind this well you
gotta you gotta put as much tension on
your inner world
of how you're thinking and how you're
feeling and how you're going to behave
as much as your outer world of
three-dimensional reality and meditation
is just a way to say okay let me get my
brain and body right I'm gonna present
Ed mylett to the world today I got one
lifetime one groundhog day one day
I just want something different
something unusual something mystical
some sign from the universe that I
created and I wanted to come in a way
that I would never think of that would
be the unknown because if I can predict
it it's the known okay let me before I
get up and grab my phone
and do all my things and get plugged
back into my Known World let me just say
okay who do I no longer want to be I
want to become so conscious that I won't
go unconscious again the fundamental
question is how many times
am I going to forget until I stop
forgetting and start remembering that is
the moment there's nothing mystical
about this
this is the work
and then you're going to say okay who do
I want to be when I open my eyes okay
let me think about this how would
greatness left we I don't know read a
book on greatness read a book on Nelson
Mandela you want to be wealthy read
about wealthy people and you're going to
see that they didn't just make their
wealth they lost a ton of money and
failed them a million times it was and
that's reality okay well let's what what
were the qualities that were they had
perseverance they had determination they
let they cut their losses they forgave
they forgot about it they went on okay
so how am I going to behave let me
rehearse how I'm going to behave
I'm going to do me take my time I have I
have plenty of time to do let me just
behave let me think about how I'm going
to behave differently in this situation
how am I going to change my emotional
response when did I fall from grace
yesterday and went back to my old self
let me just I'll set up I'll set an
alarm on my phone every three hours I'm
gonna just gonna go off and I'm gonna
take a moment and get back into the
feelings of my future okay
if I can do that over and over again
well what what do you think could happen
in my life as a result of it so
knowledge being the Forerunner the
application simple stuff simple stuff
practice hard coherence there's plenty
of stuff that we can you know we can
talk about practice brain coherence it's
we know we know I asked the brain
scientist what percentage of people at
the end of a week-long event uh what
percentage of people what have their
brains changed for the better they said
100 100 one week fully immersed in into
the experience you practice it every day
now
you can do it once or twice and say why
isn't my bank account full you know what
I'm going to tell you you're not that
good yeah that's the only reason why if
you were that good it would happen
you're not that good so show up again
and show up again and keep showing up
and I just was talking to a staff member
today the universe only gives us what we
think we're worthy of receiving right so
then people who show up for themselves
every day I believe they're worthy they
they start feeling pretty damn worthy
like hey they're like I'm worthy for
this not like an entitlement way like
something well they just like I'm I'm
really I'm real I feel like it's gonna
happen I'm worthy for it most people
number one they get up in the morning
and uh the first thing they do is they
think about the problems in their life
and those problems are memories from the
past so the moment they think about
their problems or thing in the past
right every one of those problems has an
emotion attached to them so they start
feeling unhappy or unworthy or whatever
and how you think and how you feel is
your state of being so most people's
entire state of being is in the past
when they start the day so if familiar
past they're going to live in a
predictable future right so they get up
and they check their cell phone they
check their text their WhatsApp their
Facebook they post something on Facebook
they tweet they Twitter they check the
news then they go to the bathroom get a
cup of coffee take a shower get dressed
check more emails drive to work the same
way do the same thing so for the program
they've actually lost their free will to
the program wow so if you start your day
and you start your day with this simple
question
what is the greatest ideal of myself
that I can be today you ask yourself
that question now listen your body's
going to go like well we got to get a
cup of coffee
and you got to go ah uh body
uh you're not the mind I'm the mind
right now you're gonna sit here I'm
gonna feed you uh you're gonna get your
coffee you're gonna do all those things
but right now this is my time you're
gonna obey me right so now the body's no
longer the mind you're the mind and so
when it wants to get up and you become
aware of it and we turn back to the
present moment every time you do that's
a victory and you're changing some
aspect of yourself so then
ask yourself I do this all the time
write down four thoughts that you're
going to stay conscious of the whole day
I can't it's too hard you'd be surprised
the moment you become conscious of what
those thoughts are how unconscious
you've been to them all day you know for
weeks on end write down what you speak
how you speak four things you want to
change how you act how do you how do you
act do you complain do you blame you
make excuses you feel sorry for yourself
that's a victim Consciousness what
emotions do you live by is it possible
that you're so used to living by guilt
you don't even know it's guilt it just
feels like you you allow your energy to
drop become conscious of those states of
mind and body and review them and say
this is the old self then say
what thoughts do I want to fire and wire
in my brain and start firing and wiring
and start feeling it what behaviors will
I demonstrate today what choices will I
make one day one Lifetime and just like
you did rehearse them rehearse the whole
entire thing begin to install the
neurological Hardware in your brain and
if you keep installing it the Hardwares
will become a software program and you
start thinking and acting that way and
then here's the tough part
can you teach your body emotionally
what your future is going to feel like
before it's made manifest and don't get
up until you feel that way I learned a
lot about expectation when I was
studying uh the placebo you know it's
amazing how you can give someone a sugar
pill or a saline injection or perform
some false surgery or treatment
and a certain percentage of those people
will accept believe and surrender to the
thought
that it's actually the truth without
analyzing it that they're getting an
actual real substance and their body
begins to manufacture the very Pharmacy
of chemicals uh that causes them to heal
by thought alone so the question is is
it the you know inert exogenous
substance that's doing the healing or is
it the body's innate capacity to heal so
so everybody has been conditioned to a
certain degree
whether we like it or not to rely on
something outside of us
to change our inner State and and and
and so when a person's given a pill and
it's and it's blue on one side and red
on the other and they take it and they
notice a change in their internal State
my pain has gone away uh I'm sleeping
better whatever it is
and when they notice that change in
their internal State they pay attention
to what caused it and they start to
associate and condition so well if you
keep doing that over and over again
uh that pill uh becomes a symbol of them
to change their physiology so if you
take that pill and you replace it with
something that's a nerd and they see
that pill based on conditioning when
they take that pill conditioning based
on the past they begin to expect
that outcome to happen again and the
expectation of the outcome is simply
marrying a a possibility an intention a
vision of a future outcome a new
possibility in the quantum field
and if the doctor's enthusiastic and you
name the substance something that you
can't pronounce and you charge a lot of
money for it and you use a name that
rhymes with something that could
actually you could associate as a known
uh you know Niagara and Viagra there's a
strong correlation it's a lot of flow
and and so people are conditioned to
expect an outcome so
when they start to expect the outcome
the marrying of that clear intention if
the person is optimistic if the person
is enthusiastic if the person is uh uh
grateful for the outcome a combination
of that clear intention combined with
the elevated emotion
begins to change the body's physiology
for them to manufacture their own
Pharmacy of antidepressants their own
Pharmacy of morphines are pain relievers
their own Pharmacy of dopamine by
thought alone so the question is do you
need the exogenous substance to change
your state of being or can you change
your state of being by thought alone
and by the same means if you give a
person a prognosis and you tell them
that in the chemotherapy treatments you
are going to get really nauseous and
sick they've done research on this 50 of
the people on their Drive
to the chemotherapy treatment start to
get nauseous in anticipation of the
event taking place so the question is
can 50 of the people get well on their
drive to work or they're on their drive
to their doctor in anticipation in
anticipation of getting the right
treatment in your studies with the power
of aid
if the person can assign meaning
to the value of what they're doing and
they can see oh my God energy can
actually inform matter okay that sounds
like something that makes sense give me
the quantum understanding
and you get a collective group of people
and we're discovering that Collective
networks of Observers
determine reality and you can get them
in a very specific State and the person
who's receiving the healing understands
the the value of what's taking place
the expectation of what's about to
happen if they're in a state of
gratitude it's kind of an interesting
thing gratitude when we receive
something when we've just received
something favorable when something's
happening to us that we really enjoy or
something just happened to us that
surprises us we feel gratitude so the
emotional signature of gratitude is
something's happening to us or something
favorable just happened to it it is the
ultimate state that we receive in
so if the person's in that state of
gratitude then it makes sense then
they're more susceptible to information
because we accept believe and surrender
to information equal to our emotional
state so that can actually program the
autonomic nervous system to begin to
physiologically change and that's
exactly what Pavlov did with the
salivating dogs just ring the bell and
feed them a meal and after a while the
anticipation
of the event actually causes them to
change their body's physiology their
autonomic nervous system begins to
change as if they're actually in the
process of eating the meal the
anticipation is preparing for the event
ahead of time and we can use that to so
many degrees uh in our favor if you
think that your thoughts have something
to do with your future just from a
theoretical standpoint that your
thoughts Create Your Destiny and you
think 60 to 70 000 thoughts in one day
and 90 of those thoughts are the same
thoughts as the day before well then
your life isn't going to change very
much as long as you're thinking the same
way and those those same thoughts lead
to the same choices the same choices
lead to the same behaviors the same
behaviors create the exact same
experiences and we anticipate the same
feelings or emotions from those
experiences and those emotions are the
payoff that drive our very same thoughts
well our biology our neurosurgeon
country neurochemistry our hormones and
even our gene expression will be equal
to how we think how we act and how we
feel and how we think how we act and how
we feel is called our personality and
our personality creates our personal
reality that's it so the present
personality who's listening to this show
has created the present personal reality
called their life so if you can latch on
to this idea if you want to create a new
life a new personal reality you got to
change your personality which means you
better start thinking about what you've
been thinking about and changing it you
begin to become conscious of your
unconscious actions or habits or
behaviors and modify them
and then we have to begin to look at the
emotions that we live by every single
day
keep us connected to the past and decide
do these emotions belong in our future
so most people are trying to create a
new personal reality as the same
personality and it doesn't work you
literally have to become someone else so
the principle of Neuroscience says that
nerve cells that fire together wire
together you keep thinking the same way
making the same choices demonstrating
the same habits creating the same
experiences that stamp the same networks
of neurons into the same patterns all
for the familiar feeling called you and
you do that for 10 years on end you're
going to begin to hardwire certain
patterns in your brain that becomes your
identity and by the time we're 35 years
old it kind of becomes fixed right and
psychology used to say that you can't
change that but we now know that you can
so then that kind of box in the brain
that is the habit of ourselves it's a
we're 95 of the time running a series of
programs so then sitting and doing the
work had we have to become
disentangled from those programs and so
the moment you decide to do something
differently you're making a choice but
most people don't want to face is that
discomfort and that that discomfort that
that uncertainty that lack of
predictability the that that that
unknown is what people are afraid of
because they'd rather live in guilt at
least they can predict who they're going
to be then take a chance and possibility
so when a person begins to understand
this and you say well
how long have you been this way and they
say I've been like this for 35 years and
you say why 35 years because 35 years
ago I had this one event well the
stronger the emotion you feel from the
reaction from that event the more
altered you feel inside of you the more
the brain Narrows its focus and freezes
the image and takes a snapshot and
that's called a memory right so then
forget the memory just overcome the
emotion because it's the emotion that
keeps you anchored to the past so that
sounds really good theoretically but
when you step out into that unknown into
that void
the body really is in a habit and what a
habit is when the body becomes the mind
or if you're thinking about that past
event and it's producing an emotion well
you need an image and a feeling to start
the conditioning process so the body's
either conditioned into the familiar
past or it's hardwired in the
predictable future because it wakes up
every single day and runs through the
same series of routine actions so the
present moment then becomes the unknown
when people start feeling that
discomfort today they rather get on
their cell phone and call someone or get
up and say I can't meditate or you know
I have too much to do they excuse
themselves they return back into that
familiar feeling because the body's
actually telling the brain The Habit is
when the body becomes the mind so the
body stepping out into the unknown and
says ooh I'd rather feel guilty I'd
rather feel unhappy than be in this this
conference so then at least then when
they return back to that familiar
feeling then they feel safe so they step
out in the unknown and the body starts
influencing the mind saying you can
start tomorrow you're too busy it's your
mother's fault you know it's your
culture's fault I don't have enough
money this isn't going to work
those are the programs in there that are
standing in the way between you and your
future so then nerve cells that no
longer fire together no longer wire
together so the act of observing those
states of Mind and Body
means you're no longer the program
you're the Consciousness observing that
program so so then to meditate it means
to become familiar with so as you become
familiar with those thoughts you become
conscious of how you speak you become
aware of how you act you notice how
you're feeling the more conscious you
become of those unconscious programs the
less unconscious you'll go in your
waking day why because it's not enough
to just have a great meditation and get
up and get on the freeway and get in
traffic and getting stressed you just
return back to the old self again our
job then
is to sustain that modified State of
Mind and Body the entire day and if you
can get ready because something
different or unusual is going to begin
to happen in your life and it will come
as a coincidence or synchronicity and
that's breadcrumbs from the Divine
saying you're on the path just keep
doing it there'll be another one just
keep staying in that energy and so
teaching people then to understand that
there's a formula that we now know that
if you apply that formula you'll begin
to see those changes and now as people
are doing it more and more
effectively the results are going up as
well we just had Bond University they
just took a whole bunch of my brain
scans from 10 years ago
huge clinical study a lot of analysis
and and they're Blown Away by the speed
in which the community can change brain
we're hard to coherence they they know
how to do it it's not
something that's that's separate from
them they've practiced it enough times
that they they now know how to do it so
what's the significance of that well
really simple in your life
if you start returning back to the same
reactions to the same people and
circumstances you're returning back to
the old self so you got to stay
conscious in your life and and if you're
not being defined by a vision of the
future then you're left with the
memories of the past and you will be
predictable in your life so Crossing
that River of change from the old self
to the new self there's a neurological a
biological chemical hormonal a genetic
death of the old self but if you teach
people there's something on the other
side they won't give up on themselves
they'll keep going so there's enough
evidence to encourage people and you
can't tell me you're too old to do this
work you can't tell me you're too sick
to do this work you can't tell me you
had a turbulent past or or that you're
too overweight or too underweight or too
out of shape or you can't even tell me
that you've never meditated before in
fact some of our greatest
scans or people who just have never
meditated before that are not trying to
do anything they just follow
instructions so
our community now is beginning to
understand that it is possible and they
go all in not 50 in not 60 and when we
do a week-long event we got a thousand
people or 1500 people and they are all
in and that when they start getting
Beyond themselves that first day or
second day once they start getting
Beyond themselves and that magic starts
to happen then I have no idea I can't
predict what's going to happen next and
it's usually pretty pretty exciting we
do have beliefs that feel good to us
because those beliefs are based on past
experiences and those emotions keep us
attached to the belief chemically it's
in our biology and we tend to think
neurologically and feel chemically
within experiences then that are
connected to the past so when our
beliefs are challenged we hold on to the
emotion like Jesus had a brother what
that doesn't feel right you know he was
married to Mary Magdalene you know I
mean people freak out because they've
been conditioned and they want to hold
on to that because that then ensures a
future that they can rely on
when you step out of your belief systems
and stepping into the unknown
you are now leaving behind your past and
then so then do you have the faculty
and the ability to create
do you have that ability if not because
then in order for you to go from that
Old belief to a new belief then you
better have a plan and you better be
willing to have a new experience that is
no longer a wishy-washy belief
it has to be
a very strong impression in your biology
it comes with an accompanying experience
that then changes your biology to
understand you believe something else
but that's not the end either because
then you have the question from that
point
what is the next belief that helps you
to understand the next thing for example
let's talk about it on two levels and
time out here for a second I don't care
we can go to 11 30 here oh beautiful
thank you so much it was a good
conversation so think about this
the person in our work
who I'll use a simple example
has a uh very very difficult marriage
and her marriage falls apart her husband
was abusive
and lived by the stress hormones for
extended period of time of course all
our energy is going for some threat in
our external environment she has no
energy in him her internal environment
for growth and repair no energy for
long-term building projects the the body
is in vigilance it's it's always anxious
she's anticipating something bad
happening all the time and she's got
food allergies to
everything
she's allergic to her environment
she comes to the event she does the work
it takes her three months and all of a
sudden in one event she has a
breakthrough and she's eating anything
she wants now she's changed her belief
about her past because she's no longer
saying I am this way because of my
relationship with my husband because
when you say I am this way because I had
an abusive father I am this way because
I had a difficult marriage I am this way
because I got fired from my job what
you're saying is I haven't changed since
that event emotionally
and so now you're viewing your future
through the lens of the past when you
overcome that emotional state a memory
without the emotional charge is called
wisdom
now you're ready to create a new future
because if you're still attached to the
emotion you're still attached to the
past and you can't create a future so
all of a sudden now the person has a
transformation
she had a shift she knows that she knows
that she's liberated from that anxiety
she's she feels it and as a result of it
in a matter of moments Ben or biology
reorganizes to a new mind and now she's
eating I'm watching her eat pizza I'm
watching her eat a hamburger I'm she's
laughing she's and it's and it's
sustained
but that's not the end because if she
healed herself then the next question is
I understand the physics and biology of
what I've done is it possible if I heal
myself
but I can heal another person
now my my belief is being challenged
again now I'm challenging my current
belief is it possible well I don't know
I haven't had the experience yet but if
I'm thinking it and I understand the
semantic philosophical theoretical
intellectual information can I initiate
it can I apply it can I personalize it
can I demonstrate it can I modify my
behavior in some way based on my last
experience to have a more evolved
experience and that more evolved
experience will be outside of my beliefs
currently but I understand the science
and if I can get my behaviors to match
my intentions and I've done it to myself
and quantum physics says is that
Consciousness is non-local will help if
I can create a coherent signature here I
should be able to do it in another
person
so then when the when the experience
occurs
now I have more circuitry in my brain
that's enriched I have a new feeling in
my body and I feel like a Healer I
already feel like a Healer because I've
healed myself but let me see if I can
heal someone else I'm going to bring up
that emotion and it may take me a few
times and I'm telling you that woman we
did a coherent session where we're
healing another person and the person
laying down there was a woman who from
London who had a exposure to a bacteria
in India 20 years ago who had food
allergies That Couldn't overcome that
bacteria and I watched this woman
synchronistically
unbeknownst to the woman laying down
there lay a coherent energy in that
person's body and that woman was healed
I had dinner with her in London and she
was eating salmon and rice and
everything else and she said I don't
know what happened but I got healed now
that person who did the healing
her belief was challenged and because
she had the experience she asked the
greater question so the greater question
then led to the next experience but it's
not enough to do it once
you got to be able to repeat that
experience you got to make it scientific
right you got to get it you know you're
going to make it a skill and this is
where people stop like they have the one
experience and say I'm a Healer no
the fact that you have the experience
means you should be able to reproduce
that
so then you keep pushing the boundaries
of your beliefs that's called Evolution
and so people reach a certain point in
their belief systems and they stop and
so I think the problem with a lot of
people in the spiritual Community is
they confuse Insight with belief like oh
you know I had a I have an I have an
anxiety so the reason I have anxiety
because I have a chemical imbalance in
my brain that's what my doctor told me
and I get panic attacks and I got a
panic attack on a plane and I'm afraid
of planes and crowded places and so now
that you know that you have a chemical
imbalance in your brain does it heal
your anxiety no so then they go to the
they go to the psychologist they go to
their friend their friend says well it's
not a hardware problem it's not circuits
and molecules and chemicals
a software problem you know your father
was overbearing he was a perfectionist
and and it's a soft it's a program and
you know it's from your past and
the person now has the insight
that their father was overbearing does
it heal the anxiety but they will see
that as a belief like my father was
overbearing what they're really saying
is I am this way because of this past
experience so then they go to the
psychic and the psychic says you were
burned at the stake in Carcassonne in
the 1500s you're a Charismatic Christian
the memories burned in your soul now
that you know that you are a Charismatic
Christian from the 1500s a cathar a
Templar does it heal your anxiety no so
then you go to the astrologer and she
says you know Mercury's in retrograde
don't leave the house for six months
that's the reason why the way you are
the way you are and so they develop
beliefs
that are within their emotional
acceptance
and so then they build more beliefs
within those emotions which means I
still don't want to change the Insight
doesn't change anything because people
will only accept believe and surrender
to beliefs or thoughts that are equal to
their emotional state and they'll
program their autonomic nervous system
into that Destiny so then you get a
diagnosis from a doctor it creates the
emotion of fear or desperation you'll
only accept belief and surrender to the
thoughts equal to those emotional states
until you change your emotional state is
it possible for you then to begin to
accept believe and surrender their
thoughts equal to a new emotional state
and bring up the emotion ahead of the
experience now we're talking about
going against conditioning when you
teach people how to connect to the
energy of a future dream and be defined
by a vision of the future instead of the
memories of the past to believe in their
future more than they believe in their
past
to fall in love with their future more
than they fall in love with their past
and be able to combine that clear
intention of that future
and begin to feel the emotions of that
future before it's made manifest they're
broadcasting a whole new signature into
the field now the beauty behind that is
is that the longer you're conscious of
that energy
the more you're drawing that future to
you
which also means then the moment you get
in your car and start getting angry and
getting frustrated because you're in
traffic
now you just disconnected from the
energy of your future and now you're
back to the energy of your past and
those survival emotions exert less
effects on the nature of reality so now
you feel like matter trying to change
matter you're you're separate and so you
force it you control it you try harder
you wish you pray you hope I mean hope
is a beggar we do everything compete to
try to manipulate and make it happen
because we have limited resources then
so then when a person is able to sustain
or maintain that modified state of mind
and being
then the fun starts to happen because
you start seeing those synchronicities
you start seeing those coincidences
those opportunities those unknowns those
things start falling out of nowhere
because you are connected to that field
of information and not only are you
connected to it but you're also
beginning to influence it so then more
and more people are creating now
and less of less people are experiencing
the state of being called being a victim
so then if you're a victim then you
would say I was angry because of traffic
well then I would say to you well you
mean your outer world was controlling
how you think and feel some circumstance
some person something in your outer
world is actually controlling your
feelings and thoughts that means you're
a victim to those circumstances but when
you change the way you think and feel
and it starts to produce effects in your
outer world now you start to realize
you're the creator of your life and the
moment you start seeing feedback in your
life
you're going to pay attention to what
you did and you're going to do it again
and now you're going to believe now
you're more of the creator of your life
and less of the victim of your life most
people die because they're in a genetic
program
that
if you were truly living completely in
the present moment all of your attention
and energy were in the present moment
then you would be out of the program yes
or no
where are you I didn't want to lose
contact with you
so it would make sense then that when
your body is programmed into a
predictable future based on what you've
did in the past then it's it's almost
like a predetermined Destiny yes or no
another way to say it is you're rushing
to your death
I don't know how else to say that you
get it so imagine as I said all week so
far the genes that have been signaled
and certain genes are more hardwired
than others and when you notice that
tendency when you're at home and you
want to get up and start your day and
you got emails and and you just go oh
wait a second and you come back to the
present moment that's unnatural
that goes against the program and people
lose their free will to a program and
all of a sudden now the will is getting
greater than the program and they're
literally changing a line of time that's
what we're doing
are you with me still come on so
there's not a lot of evidence
that shows that people can be immortal
and yet there's an immortal Gene cancer
cells have the immortal genes signaled a
lot of times so then your will to live
has to be greater than your fear of
dying
are you with me still
so then if there's an immortality Gene
then on some level it has to be selected
and instructed yes or no and there are
fables whether you believe them or not
historic figures charismatic leaders
Spiritual Beings that have overcome
death are you with me still now I'm sure
here we go my mother's gonna love this
I'm sure that Jesus you know the night
before his crucifixion I'm sure he
wasn't saying man I'm just not up for
this
I got a headache I'm a little anxious
I'm a little worried
he he took it on because that was his
initiation if you're not being defined
by a vision of the future
then you're left with the old memories
of the past and you will be predictable
in your life
and if you wake up in the morning and
you're not being defined by a vision in
the future as you see the same people
and you go to the same places and you do
the exact same thing at the exact same
time
it's no longer that your personality is
creating your personal reality now your
personal reality is affecting or
creating your personality your
environment is really controlling how
you think and feel unconsciously because
every person everything every place
every experience has a neurological
Network in your brain every experience
that you have with every person produces
an emotion so some people will use their
boss to reaffirm their addiction to
judgment they'll use their enemy to
reaffirm their addiction to hatred
they'll use their friends to reaffirm
their addiction to suffering so now they
need the outer world to feel something
so
to change then is to be greater than
your environment to be greater than the
conditions in your world and the
environment is that seductive so then
why is meditation the tool well
let's sit down let's Close Our Eyes
let's disconnect from your outer
environment so if you're seeing less
things there's less stimulation going to
your brain if you're playing soft music
or you have earplugs in less sensory
information coming to your brain so
you're disconnecting from your
environment if you can sit your body
down
and tell it to stay like an animal stay
right here I'm going to feed you when
we're done you can get up and check your
emails you can do all your texts but
right now you're going to sit there and
obey me
so then when you do that properly and
you're not eating anything or smelling
anything or tasting anything you're not
up experiencing and feeling anything you
would have to agree with me that you're
being defined by a thought right so when
the body wants to go back to its
emotional past
and you become aware that your attention
is on that emotion and where you place
your attention is where you place your
energy you're siphoning your energy out
of the present moment into the past and
you become aware of that
and you settle your body back down in
the present moment because it's saying
well it's eight o'clock you normally get
upset because you're in traffic around
this time and here you are sitting and
we're used to feeling anger and you're
off schedule oh it's 11 o'clock and
usually check your emails and judge
everybody well the body's looking for
that that predictable chemical state
every time you become aware that you're
doing that and your body is craving
those emotions and you settle it back
down into the present moment you're
telling the body
it's no longer the mind that you're the
mind and now your will is getting
greater than the program and if you keep
doing this over and over again over and
over again over and over again just like
training a stallion or a dog it's just
gonna say well I'm gonna sit and the
moment that happens when the body's no
longer the mind when it finally
surrenders there's a liberation of
energy
we go from particle to wave from matter
to energy and we free ourselves from the
chains of those emotions that keep us in
the in the familiar past and we've seen
this thousands of times in fact we can
actually predict it now on a brain scan
it's so important for people
to remember that they're the creators of
their lives instead of the victim of
their lives right so the victim is
saying I'm feeling this way because that
person that circumstance or I don't have
any money is causing me to feel this way
this is my relationship with money what
that really means is I'm using my lack
to reaffirm my dependency my addiction
my conditioning that's my relationship
with money is that I put my attention on
money because I don't have it so the
relationship with money is of course
built on lack and so when they don't
have it they feel bad and what they're
really saying is my outer environment my
reality is actually controlling the way
I feel the way I think so Lewis why are
you in a good mood today things are
going good why in a bad mood things are
going bad today so
this unconscious program victimization
is saying that that that we're we're
allowing our environment to influence
the way we feel and the way we think
isn't that isn't that what victimization
is and and the stronger the emotion we
have to our lack the more we put our
attention on the fact that we don't have
it right so then the person has
forgotten that they're creating reality
because what they're creating is lack
and they're creating more of it and then
they try harder and they force harder
and they come they're so exhausted and
their body's tired and they're breaking
down right so so the experiment then is
let's try it another way let's create
from the field instead of from matter
can a coherent heart get a coherent
brain relax in the heart and energy
moves right in the brain we've measure
this thousand times and all of a sudden
the person moves into these beautiful
elegant brainwave states where they're
super creative right so the the longer
you're conscious of that energy the more
you draw that future to you so then what
is the synchronicity mean it means
whatever you're doing inside of you is
producing that effect outside of you pay
attention to what you did again so
generate a little bit more abundance
just do it for an experiment now when
the synchronicity happens do you think
you feel suffering or do you think you
feel a little excitement you feel
inspired right so then that
synchronicity is saying use this energy
use this feeling it should be easier for
you to feel this now and go back and do
it again keep the experiment going
and here comes the promotion here comes
the here comes the email here comes the
person you meet at the right time right
well we have something happening here
and then that that becomes the momentum
right
so then we generate abundance that's
that's how we do it and the relationship
doesn't just happen by accident we
generate we generate abundance right so
then if you have an hour meditation
where you're tuning into your abundant
future
but then you're spending the other 15
hours a day in lack don't expect
anything to change your defaulted since
you're back to the old energy and if you
say it's that person or that
circumstance or that bank account I'm
going to say you're back to the
unconscious program being a victim right
and so then so then
so then let's go a step further
if your personality creates your
personal reality and it does and your
personality is made up of how you think
how you act and how you feel then the
present personality who's listening to
this podcast has created the present
personal reality called their life
nothing big there which means if you
want to change your personal reality
you're going to have to change your
personality right nothing changes in
your life until you change don't expect
anything in your life to change if your
environment
is controlling your feelings and
thoughts and if your environment is
controlling how you feel and think and I
say to you Bobby why are you so upset
today oh well this person is upsetting
me what you're really saying is that
person
is controlling your feelings and your
thoughts and that means you're a victim
to your environments well to turn that
around and you start realizing your
feelings and thoughts create your
environment
and you start seeing the effects of you
at cause
you're going to react less the people in
your life because you're going to
understand that you'll be back to the
victim Consciousness and and when you
start seeing that you're creating
outcomes in your life you're going to
believe more that you're the creator of
your life unless the victim of your life
and I say the more you practice it
the better you get at it I think uh yeah
to heal by thought alone uh we have to
demystify the process so let's answer
the question on two levels okay
let's answer it in terms of the placebo
and then let's answer in terms of what
we can teach people in order to do that
okay so if you think about the placebo
how is it that you can give someone a
sugar pill
saline injection or perform some false
surgery or treatment
and a certain percentage of those people
will accept believe and surrender to the
thought that they're getting the real
substance or treatment without any
analysis they begin to program their
autonomic nervous system
to make their own Pharmacy of chemicals
that matches the exact chemical or
treatment they think they're getting now
was it the inert substance the placebo
that was doing the healing or was it the
thought that was doing the healing
so there are numerous cases in science
that show that between 10 and 100
percent of certain studies that are
placebo-based triple blind studies
people heal by thought alone all the
time so here's the question
do you need
the inner substance to do the healing or
if you understand the science and
mechanics of how the placebo Works can
you teach people instead of putting
their faith and belief in some exogenous
substance something outside of them like
a pill something certainly known can you
begin to put your faith and belief in
yourself
and begin to select an unknown in the
quantum field a new possibility that
already exists
and do the exact same thing you did with
the placebo but believe in a future
and allow your body to begin to respond
to a new mind and the answer to the
question is yes because we've measured
it enough times in our studies with the
brain so that's Point number one
the second point that is important to
understand is that people only accept
believe and surrender to the thoughts
that are equal to their emotional state
they'll never accept believe and
surrender to any other thoughts that are
not equal to their emotional state so if
you get a diagnosis in the first emotion
you feel after the diagnosis is fear or
sadness
you can think positively all you want
with five percent now this assigns five
percent of your conscious mind
but who you are by the time you're 35
years old is a subconscious program of
beliefs perceptions attitudes emotional
reactions unconscious habits and
behaviors
so then the person gets a diagnosis
they're feeling fear thoughts are the
language of the brain feelings are the
language of the body
they're thinking positively with the
five percent of their conscious mind but
they're feeling fear
and they could do that all they want but
it's never going to get beyond their
analytical mind and begin to have an
effect on the body so mind and body are
working in opposition
that means also then that if you can
change a person's
emotional state
to gratitude
to inspiration to Hope
to love
that means that they'll accept believe
and surrender to the thoughts equal to
that emotional state and they'll begin
to program their autonomic nervous
system into a different Pharmacy of
chemicals now let's just make this very
clear now in Placebo studies
81 percent of people who have
uh depression if they're in a placebo
study and 81 of those people who are
taking the placebo actually respond as
well to the placebo as they would to an
antidepressant 81 that's a pretty high
study what that means is they're making
their own Pharmacy of antidepressants
right within the nervous system it's the
greatest pharmacist in the world
so what's the revelance uh the
significance of that significance is
really simple
and people begin to change their
emotional state they begin to alter who
they are
it may take more than one attempt at
this because in that Placebo study they
took the placebo for six to eight weeks
now the pill represented the possibility
of them getting well they're thought
when they start looking forward to or
anticipating getting better and they
feel inspired when you combine a clear
intention with an elevated emotion
you're moving into a new state of being
now the brain and body are no longer
living in the past
the brain and body are living in the
future in the present moment and they're
beginning to produce substantial
neurological biological and genetic
changes in the body
but the placebo study for depression
that person took the pill for six to
eight weeks which means you may actually
have to change your state of being for
six to eight weeks before you begin to
see the change so I don't want this to
be a Panacea where you do it once and
you're better our students have healed
themselves a very significant
very very uh
most almost predestined genetic
conditions that medical science had no
solution for not just one student with
one condition but other students with
the same condition now we're seeing a
trend but it took them some of those
people
two years to do it by thought alone
so they wanted it more than their sleep
they wanted it more than their pain they
wanted it more than their social
interactions or social occasions they
wanted more than breakfast to them it
was the most important thing so every
single day they took the placebo by
thought alone
and by doing that over time they were
able to turn the battleship around
so it takes uh developing the skill it
takes the science of understanding how
it works it takes changing a belief or
perception that you have about yourself
and your life and it's going to take you
feeling a little bit uncomfortable in
the process of doing it but to heal my
thought alone means that you have to get
to the point where you literally are
thought alone that's when you begin to
see the significant changes so in a
sense then it's not the personality that
chooses the body or the parents or it's
the soul that chooses it does that make
sense but if a person gets caught in
routine and gets lost in the Quagmire of
life
then the ego takes over and the soul is
diminished
and now the person is doing their best
to become a somebody a someone on
something be somewhere in some time and
of course if that's the journey
and the person's not willing to find
wisdom or look for truth then they can
play on that level for as long as they
want until they're tired of it and when
they finally get bored with it and
they'll they'll want to choose something
else and Eternity is a long time
wouldn't you agree
so then the Soul then says okay here's
the options probable lines of time there
are probable lines of time that are the
more probable than others
and
there is a probable line of time for
living in the same body and raising your
frequency to the point where you can go
wherever you want with your body that's
the ultimate yes or no and you can whip
red out of nothing and you can be in two
places at once and you can be on the the
uh an alternate universe and have a
whole life there and you can be
dimensional that's that's the freedom of
when you've mastered yourself and you've
mastered the conditions
but most of us
are headed in a certain timeline based
on our genes and based on our own
personal Evolution and that's what makes
this time right now
so powerful
this time right now is the age of
information
and an age of information ignorance is
actually a choice
and people are beginning to realize that
I don't need a doctor to find out what
my disease is I don't need to go to the
library or talk to my teacher I can just
I can just find the information and
people are starting to wake up to
Greater understandings and that is
starting to become the collective and
that Collective energy in the field the
collective Consciousness the collective
awareness is changing the future of
humanity yes or no and at the same time
past this crumbling
there is economic collapse there's
political collapse there's religious
collapse there's environmental collapse
there's there's all of that is breaking
down journalistic collapse and well who
watches the news and expects to hear the
truth I mean it's just all falling apart
and it's becoming so obvious to people
that all of a sudden they're realizing
that the people that run the world or
people that are in places of Power are
actually really really worse off than
you and I
and the only thing that has to happen is
that we have to collectively become one
mind
and when we collectively become one mind
we no longer are seduce by those things
and we are now like a flock of birds all
moving in the same direction and those
fish all of a sudden moving as a school
nobody's leading everybody's leading
we're just connected and what do you
think we're doing when you tune in to
the power of love in this room don't you
know everybody dialing into that same
frequency is causing that frequency to
be in this room and if everybody's doing
it it's getting more collimated more
coherent more organized and if you put
your attention on it there's more of it
so then when you're leading with your
heart that's enough
that's enough
so then when you have a collective mind
and people are moving in that way and
they're no longer reacting to politics
or whatever and they no longer need
those things you're catching somebody
who's starting to awaken
yes or no and if you're focusing on the
Divine and that's where all of your
attention is you won't see ethnicity you
won't see skin color you won't see
anything of Separation you'll just be
like wow
nice costume to the masquerade I should
have wore that
it's crazy because then people go get
their genetics found out and you know
some of them you know just really have
an intolerance to some culture and
they're 40 percent of that culture
so
what makes this time for me so unique
and I'm speaking
personally
is that there's such a quickening going
on more things are happening in a
shorter amount of time would you agree
and if more things are happening in a
shorter amount of time it becomes more
difficult to predict the next moment
this point we're reaching this nodal
point is the point of in
unpredictability and the old is
collapsing and the collapsing of the old
should never be faced with fear with
bigotry with with with anger with
hostility with guilt sadness and shame
because that's how we've been controlled
all along
and by the way
I mean I'm not a conspiracy theorist but
if you want to control people manipulate
their emotions so as we move closer and
closer to that point the probability of
US changing our life the length of our
life not from low stress foods and not
from vitamins all those things are good
matter to matter
but stress is going to down regulate the
gene consume the body's energy and now
that's going to begin to Signal the gene
to produce the disease that the person
has inherited in the first place
are you with me still so when you react
to someone or something and you're
living by the same emotional state you
keep the same genes on the same genes
off and that's your genetic Destiny and
now the Awakening of this even if I
even if we change little timelines just
this week we changed lines of time
you've changed something about yourself
you are going to walk into a different
future that is your genetic timeline and
now you're bumped off course you just
got to be willing to stay in the unknown
and be comfortable with it and that's
when you're at your greatest if you're
if you're truly
in the business of change or creating
your life that's a big responsibility
yeah right I mean like we we ran our
event I said to the audience okay nobody
nobody forced you to come here right you
came here on your own you took the risk
in coming here
by coming here you also agree that
you create your reality that you're
responsible for yourself and your life
so if something happens to you you can't
blame anybody because of that it's your
responsibility to take care of you right
so then the fundamental question is and
I ask myself this all the time
at what point
do I stop believing
that I create my life at what point when
things go bad then all of a sudden I
didn't create that
that person is doing it to me right so
if we can if we can wire that in our
brains right that
our reaction and response to an
environmental condition
is causing us
to go back to the past that's what the
emotion is the familiar emotion is the
past
and I'm on the journey and I catch
myself doing that
if I'm truly in the practice every day
and I can cultivate a feeling not not on
the spot then
that you you're not prepared
your meditation is the preparation of
mind and body for this
so I don't get up from my meditation
until I'm in love with life I don't I
don't create anything that's going to be
unlimited until I feel unlimited am I in
that space and if I'm practicing feeling
unlimited every day and practice
connecting to the emotions of my future
I'm I'm out of the bleachers and I'm on
the field if you're in the bleachers and
you're trying to not react to people in
in circumstances you don't have the
practice or the skill set
on how to create that emotion because
you haven't been practicing creating it
and why do we close our eyes and do it
because the environment is so seductive
why do we sit still and not move because
you're going to want to get up and pee
and eat and have a cup of coffee and
feel so so now you're telling your body
hey stay
I'm gonna feed you yeah you're gonna
take a shower you're gonna get coffee
you can play with your cell phone you
could text you can talk trash you can do
anything you want but right now you're
not the mind I'm the mind and you're
gonna sit and stay till I'm done and
when I condition you to the emotions of
the future and I get a very clear image
of who I'm going to be this day
and I'm not going to get up until I feel
that way
I guarantee you you're going to come up
against all those unconscious thoughts
they're going to come up right there I
want people to I want them to see it I
want them to become so familiar with it
so conscious if they wouldn't go
unconscious they wouldn't let that
thought I can't ever slip by an
awareness unchecked they've done the
work in the beginning of the day they
suppress those circuits in the brain and
nerve cells that no longer fire together
no longer wire together you're you're
breaking down the old personality and so
you say ah your body wants to get up I
gotta pee I want to have a couple I want
to check and you you watch your body
want to get up and you go hey hey hey
hey hey hey get over here you you get
back into this present moment and you
every time you do that it's a victory
you're executing a will that's greater
than an unconscious program and most
people lose their free will to a program
because they do the same thing today as
they did yesterday their body's on
autopilot and it's dragging them into
the same future habitually based on what
they did in the past so now you're
sitting there and it's just a little
uncomfortable and you want quit in your
body and you go
no
you get over here and you bring it back
now some people say I can't meditate but
really they're actually doing it right
that's a victory too and then you do
that and you start watching how you're
training your body back into the present
moment then it's your body says well
you know Lewis it's uh it's it's 8 30 in
the morning this is usually when you
watch the news and throw a tirade and
get angry right and you're what's
sitting here with your eyes closed and
you're off schedule so why don't we just
get agitated about anything so the body
starts trying to create images in your
mind so you remember your ex you
remember your problems so you could feel
that agitation what if you watched your
body do that and you said
no no no no no I'm not going to give my
power away to the past or that person
that circumstance in my life you get
that body back in the present moment you
lower the volumes of that emotion
that's a victory you're telling the body
it's no longer the mind that you're the
mind now that kind of work
is tedious in the beginning but I watch
people because when I have them do that
it starts stretching their boundaries
the known self that little box starts to
move into the unknown and they survive
and all of a sudden they're more relaxed
in the present moment the unknown and I
start feeling more satisfied so now
they're more ready to create so the
preparation for the day is to remind
yourself of who you no longer want to be
to know thyself to become so familiar
with the word meditation means to become
familiar with so conscious of your
unconscious programs you're not going to
go unconscious why because you did you
did battle today with that personality
that's creating the same personal
reality and if your personality is made
up of how you think how you act and how
you feel and you want to create new
personal reality then you got to change
your personality and that's gonna mean
then you're gonna become so conscious of
those unconscious programs that you're
no longer the program you're the
Consciousness observing the program
disentangling from that
is not easy that's why most people won't
do it that's why they get on their cell
phone and say let me just create a
little dopamine by just seeing if I got
a text from somebody I like you know
your phone's over there and you're no
longer regulating with something outside
of you this is this is game time so then
if you said
what thoughts do I want to fire and wire
in my brain with my attention and my
intention I think we're a reality
producing machines I mean there's no
there's no single individual on this
planet who doesn't create reality unless
they have a brain injury or something
but for the most part most of us are
engaged in reality you know and we do
cause effects I think we reach a certain
point in our life where we stop learning
and we start feeling and when we use
feelings as a barometer for the unknown
it's a it's it's contraindicated because
feelings are usually a record of a past
experience so we try to predict how that
future event is going to be based on a
Feeling and we always return back to the
old self again so I love the idea of how
we can actually produce effects I love
the idea that every human being is
either lives in one of two states of
mind we either live in creation which is
growth and expansion and and it's um
health and homeostasis the emotions of
love and joy and Trust make us feel
connected to something bigger than us or
we live in a state of survival and the
state of survival is living in stress
and living in stress is when your body
is knocked out of balance and the
redundancy of that cycle over time that
imbalance that keeps happening begins to
break the body down and I think the
biggest problem for us because of the
size of our brains is we can turn on a
stress response just by thought alone
and we do it all day long
in that continuous redundant
being out of balance over time that
imbalance becomes the new balance and
now we're headed for contraction and
disease and feeling separate from the
field and being selfish instead of
selfless we begin to
live in a state of breakdown in a state
of um
uh disease and a lack of health and and
so then those emotions then of those
survival chemicals endorse the ego and
then we become more self-indulgent and
more self-important and more
self-serving
because that's what those chemicals do
so
we live in one of those two states of
mind now those chemicals tend to be
highly addictive so this is really good
dinner conversation we can talk about it
right
but actually breaking through that's I
think when you free yourself from the
chains of those emotions that that we
memorize when we actually break through
and our when we remove
that mind out of the body when we break
the emotion that's trapped in physical
flesh and the body's liberated that's
true self-love that's true Joy it's the
liberation of energy so the anger that
once was in there the hatred that was
once into the Prejudice that was once in
there is transformed it's transmuted
into joy and it's the same energy but it
just has a different spin
and so no one can do that for you
you know that that isn't something where
someone you know waves a wand and then
it happens you have to actually be
willing to be uncomfortable
as you break that addiction and be okay
with it and then the moment the body's
liberated and you feel that expansion
that's the natural state of being now
you say I love myself so much because I
went further than I thought I could go
I transcended some limitation about
myself in the way I think in the way I
act in the way I feel that's the
personality that's the identity
changing one of those things
really changing and not just like
changing your mind like I want vanilla
ice cream instead of chocolate ice cream
but truly changing something that
changes your neurology or neural
circuitry changes the chemistry which is
your emotions that signal the gene that
begins to change your very expression of
Health in a very expression of life
[Music]
talking about when you make that
emphatic you know declaration word
you make that change
and it's undeniable
there's a biological neurological and
Quantum effect as a result of it well I
think I flirt primarily with the idea of
how subjective mind has an effect on the
objective world
you know Newtonian physics is about
cause and effect it's about something
outside of you fundamentally changing
something inside of you you know we are
an expression or a reflection of the
environment
so
as long as the environment is
influencing how we're thinking and
feeling we can only be as great as the
environment so and if we're thinking and
feeling equal to the environment we
could only create more of the same
environment you know the idea that we
can change something inside of us in our
in our Consciousness and our thoughts
and in our feelings
and be able to memorize both
neurologically in our brain and hardwire
that information install hardware and
condition the body emotionally to be a
mind so mind and body are working
together
if we're able to maintain that modified
state of being then
there should be some evidence outside of
us so instead of cause and effect
I always love the idea of causing
effects and to cause an effect so the
quantum model says you can cause an
effect and so I think where we get stuck
with that is the idea that you know that
it has to be predictable that we should
be able to know how it's going to happen
and and that is that is I think our
biggest error because we can never
control the outcome of the unpredictable
that's the quantum model it has to be
uncertain it has to come in a way that
we least expect that surprises us that
that leaves no doubt that what we did
inside of us produced some effect
outside of us and and when you begin to
have those small synchronicities at
first and then they turn into larger and
larger events and you experience that
that awe and that Wonder or that joy and
appreciation for being alive I think
that's the natural state of being I
think that's
having that kind of sensibility coming
from within us instead of needing
something outside of us to change our
state how often do you find yourself in
reaction mode when someone throws you
under the bus whether it's someone
honking at you in a car and you say ah
this how often do you give back to that
place and
like because we're aren't we conditioned
to kind of react dude I react every day
oh my God I react every day but the
fundamental question is
how long are you gonna react right so
shortening the refractory period of your
emotional reactions is that kind of
intelligence where we're keeping
ourselves out of the past Justified
valid or not the only person that that's
affecting is you and then you have to
ask yourself is it loving to me well if
you can't control that emotional
reaction then you're a junkie and you're
on a bad trip and you're overdosing but
if you know that you're overdosing you
got to get beyond your rational mind
because you'll say why are you this way
all right by you doing that is it making
more of those chemicals yeah why what
are you doing that to make you feel more
like it's it's Justified so then
oh this takes was I excuse myself
many times in one day because you'll be
I'm in a reaction
are you like I'll be like are you
kidding me what who what did they do
and then I'll be like oh we're not gonna
make a decision in this state so give me
a minute oh wow I go take a few breaths
get out of that state remember my future
where I'm going it's so much more
important than the present moment I just
got to condition my body into that
future and now it takes
sometimes a Herculean effort I have to
tell you my staff I'll be in my I'll be
in there 15 20 30 minutes sometimes I'll
say I work it took me an hour
in in the expanse of all eternity
if I don't overcome that emotion
then I'm in my past and that's Karma
because that emotion is gonna drive my
behaviors and thoughts and I'm going to
be predictable my past is going to look
my future's gonna look a lot like my
past so if I'm soulfully on the journey
um then what matters the most is being
able to learn the skill of
self-regulation so in our in our events
when we see people that can do brain and
heart coherence they know the formula
when I look at their brain scans and I'm
like loose Great Brain hey you got you
can I I see you can hold that heart
coherence for 45 minutes great now let's
put you on a poll at 55 feet in the air
let's get a heart rate monitor on you
and let's see what you're going to do up
there do you want to be able to
self-regulate there because if you can
there it's not like I'm trying to give
you an adrenaline rush actually I'm
trying to do the opposite I want you to
settle your brain body back down go
against thousands of years of
programming like fear and teach your
body in that moment how to regulate I
guarantee you if you go a little further
than what you did and you stay conscious
instead of throwing in a program and
rushing through it and trying to get it
over with you start breathing you start
getting back in your heart you start
getting centered you work against those
chemicals I guarantee you when you walk
into your life
you're gonna the moment you see somebody
you're gonna catch on right away You're
Gonna Catch yourself now that that saves
you a lot of energy
and a lot of time because if you're able
to change it then instead of four hours
later where you're just yeah gone or
you've already reacted yeah and and
you've done things you said I you say I
should have never done that I should
have never said that that's what those
emotions do because those emotions make
us really primitive really primitive
we're either going to be coming we're
going to become antagonistic and angry
and aggressive we're gonna run and fear
and or we're gonna hide like that's
really the option when you begin to
create from the field
instead of from matter the only way you
can do that is you have to learn how to
take all of your attention off your body
and become a nobody
take all of your attention off all the
people in your life that you give so
much of your attention and energy to
because you have an emotion associated
with them and get beyond all the people
in your life and go from someone to a no
one now if you've worked your whole life
being a someone or if you've been
working your whole life thinking that
you're your body you're gonna have to
work a little harder because that's your
identity that's what you're associated
with and it's a long time of
conditioning and if this was easy
everybody would be doing it so then you
have to go get beyond all the things in
your life your cell phone your computer
your car
and literally go from something to
nothing if I take all your attention off
the place you work the place you live
the place you need to be the place
you're sitting and go from somewhere to
nowhere
you got to stop thinking about the
predictable future and the familiar past
and go right into the present moment and
go from some time to no time and if you
do that properly
you become pure Consciousness that's how
you enter the field now we've done the
research on this we call it getting
beyond the self now once you are pure
Consciousness you're taking all of your
attention off this three-dimensional
reality now where you place your
attention is where you place your energy
so if you've taken all of your attention
off of everything material
there's only one place you're going to
wind up and that is the in in material
realm called the quantum field an
invisible field of energy that unifies
and connects everything material
so now when you're creating from the
field and you combine a clear intention
with an elevated emotion and you're
connected and you feel connected
the suggestion of an alternative way to
create is that when there's a
vibrational match between your energy
and some future reality
you actually no longer have to go
anywhere to get it you're actually the
vortex and you will collapse space and
time and draw the experience to you now
that to me is a lot more fun because the
experience is the unknown you can't
predict when it's going to happen or how
it's going to happen because if you can
predict it it's known so then you have
to lay down the very thing
you use your whole life to get what you
want
for something greater to occur now that
goes against
Generations Untold of conditioning and a
lifetime of habituation believing that
we're we're trapped in this material
world and yet I can I can say to you
without a doubt
that once you understand that formula
and once you know how to create that
kind of brain and heart coherence the
side effect of that
is a change in biology
neurologically chemically hormonally
genetically we've measured it we've seen
Gene regulation changes in four days
more brain coherence more heart
coherence your brain's working better
your heart is you're trusting your heart
it's open there's different chemicals
that are released oxytocin suppresses
survival centers resets the Baseline of
a person's trauma or shock
your immune system goes up
you you lengthen your telomeres we've
measured that too so you're changing the
future of your body you're extending
your life
that's evidence right so we we have the
evidence the know that it could happen
because we've measured it but the real
evidence
is watching the testimonial of someone
who says I had stage four cancer I was
told as a 41 year old woman that I
wouldn't live for more than two months
and I have no
evidence of cancer in my body at all or
someone that's a physician who has
Parkinson's disease that's tried
everything from the medical route and
has one transcendental moment and their
Tremors and their pain are gone now
they're chewing food they're swallowing
they're blowing their nose they're
standing up on their own uh that's
energy affecting matter so we have
hundreds and hundreds of testimonials of
people that not only heal their body but
created pretty profoundly magical things
in their life
so you have evidence in the scientific
world you have evidence in the Practical
world and evidence
is the loudest voice right now the brain
is a record of the past it's an artifact
of everything we've learned and
experienced to this moment so most
people wake up in the morning and they
think about their problems and their
problems are memories that are etched in
their brain that are connected to
certain people and certain problems of
certain times in certain places and the
moment they start thinking of their
problems they're thinking in the past
the challenge is that every one of those
problems has an emotion associated with
it and emotions really are a record of
the past so the moment you feel unhappy
the moment you feel suffering the moment
you feel
fear now your body's in the past so it's
the thought being the language of the
brain and the feeling being the language
or the body and how we think and how we
feel creates our state of being so many
people reaffirm their state of being
completely by the past and so it only
takes a thought and a feeling an image
an emotion a stimulus in response to
start the conditioning process so we
start to condition the brain and body
hardwire the brain condition the body
emotionally into the past the problem is
the body's so objective that it doesn't
know the difference between the real
life experience that's creating the
emotion and the emotion we're creating
by memory alone the body's believing us
living in the same past environment 24
hours a day seven days a week 365 days a
year so
and the person gets up and then they run
through the same routine as they always
do and uh in time their body moves into
a state of autopilot now their body is a
set of programs a habit that's dragging
them into the same future based on what
they did in the past and so to change
them also requires being greater than
the emotions that have been conditioned
into the body and the habituations that
have been conditioned into the body in
the predictable future so we have to
understand then that change requires not
only being created in the environment
but also being greater than our body
which is really for the most part been
conditioned to be the mind that's what a
habit is
so then
to change them to be greater than the
body to be greater than the environment
and be greater than time instead of
living in the familiar past which is the
known and the predictable future which
is the known you teach people how to
settle into the present moment and
that's the unknown and most people that
the unknown represents a very
threatening place and so when people
start to do meditation as an example and
their body starts looking for an arousal
or wants to get up and do things they
think they can't meditate but in fact if
they can settle their body back down
into the present moment and lower the
volume to that anger to that frustration
to the fear to the sadness
it's like training an animal now you're
telling the body it's no longer the mind
that you're the mind and our research
shows there's a liberation of energy the
body starts expanding and relaxing into
the present moment instead of getting up
and checking your cell phone or doing
something and you notice that propensity
instead of responding to it and say I
can't meditate you settle your body back
down into the present moment now you're
executing a will
that's greater than the program because
most people lose their free will to a
set of programs and it's the act of
doing this to be greater than the
conditions our environment to be greater
than our body as the mind and and to be
greater than time
that all of a sudden causes the person
to start believing in themselves a
little bit more and that's when um
possibility starts to unfold let's say
you've had some pretty rough experiences
in your past
and those experiences cause you to feel
sad and unworthy and guilty
and judgmental
and you've gotten so used to feeling
guilty and unworthy and judgmental that
that's just feels normal to you
and then because you feel kind of
victimized
then you blame people and you complain
and you make excuses and you feel sorry
for yourself and that's your personality
and all of a sudden you say today
I'm not going to do that any longer
because that's the old self
and then you start off your day and it
goes really well for about two hours
and then all of a sudden the moment you
realize that you're no longer making the
same choices as the day before you are
going to feel uncomfortable
it's going to feel unfamiliar
it's going to be uncertain there's going
to be some unpredictability
and we now know that people would rather
hold on to their guilt and unworthiness
than to step into the unknown
because at least they can feel something
and so the moment you stop making the
same choices that you always make get
ready because it's going to be
uncomfortable and that's the moment
you're heading towards the new self
and we call it stepping into the river
of change
but now remember 95 of who you are is
your body as the mind
you know you've done something enough
times that your body does it better than
your brain
so you may actually complain
unconsciously because your body does it
all the time
and all of a sudden you say no
complaining
no more blaming no more feeling sorry
for myself no more talking about other
people I'm gonna stop
you know what happens don't you
the body starts sending signals to the
brain
the body's been conditioned that way
and all of a sudden you start hearing
the thoughts in your head
that say why don't you start tomorrow
's a better day
this is too hard for me I can't change
something's wrong with me it's my
mother's fault it's my ex-husband's
fault it's my ex-wife's fault I'm this
way because of this event or the most
important one this doesn't feel right
and the moment you respond to that
thought is if it's true
that thought leads to the same Choice
which leads to the same behavior that
creates the same experience that
produces the same emotion and the person
says this feels right
that feels familiar
going from the old self to the new self
stepping into that void stepping into
that uncertainty is the biological the
neurological the chemical the hormonal
genetic death of the old self
and people will say to us well in that
unknown I can't predict my life or my
future
and we always say the same thing to them
the best way to predict your future is
to create it not from the known but from
the unknown
and when you and I get comfortable in
the place of the unknown that's where
the magic happens and it never happens
in the known I think it's more important
to have fun I think as I play with this
you know like it's not that you react I
mean we all react the question is how
long yeah and so so like
learning how to shorten the refractory
period of your emotional responses is
worth more than all the gold in the
world because if you can't control your
emotional reactions to conditions in
your life they turn in the moods those
are one long emotion the temperaments
and ultimately personality and so then
learning how to do that and catching
yourself is the learning process and
that's so important for a perfectionist
to see it as like hey I did pretty good
I did I fell off the horse I got back on
not a big deal I'm gonna keep going yeah
the person who says oh I failed I'm but
not good at this you know I'm gonna get
sick again that's that's a huge default
and that's kind of talking ourselves out
of change it's so important for us
to realize that this is a very
uh intense process it takes an enormous
amount of awareness an enormous amount
of energy to master yourself in that
moment because valid Justified or not
the only person that is hurting is you
and when you finally figure that out as
my daughter would say living by this
emotion isn't loving to me and and and
we have to really decide is this loving
to me so so it turns out when
you teach people how to feel elevated
emotions they make some so many
wonderful chemicals that make them feel
good that they're no longer dependent on
anything outside of them to take away
their emptiness their lack their
separation their pain Their Fear they're
actually learning how to do it without
any exogenous substance without anything
outside of them without any scrolling
through anything there this feels way
better than any of that now that's the
moment
where we're all of a sudden free from
our environment and and and people
self-regulate and when that happens
their health gets better they have a
headache it improves they have pain it
changes they learn that they can do it
by thought alone how valuable is that I
don't know if we could teach our kids
that it would be amazing that sounds
really easy but when it comes down to
feeling gratitude before the experience
most people go uh yeah I gotta go yeah I
didn't really feel it you know but the
person who says I'm not getting up I'm
just not gonna get up
until I open my heart to life now to me
that's that's a willingness so then as
they trade guilt and suffering for joy
and freedom and they and inspiration and
a love for life and they're doing it
without relying on anything outside of
them
they're going to be more prone to no
longer need anything outside of them to
make them feel that way they're going to
feel that way naturally and then
everybody's going to be really
suspicious like he changed his
medication oh he's doing something he's
not telling me you know you're going to
show up unpredictable in your life and
that's when we begin to become
outstanding or Supernatural or
extraordinary but
you can't take
any of that with you to become someone
else and if someone says to me well I
really can't do it because I've had this
experience 22 years ago or 30 years ago
I'm going to say to you that event
had such a strong emotion
that you haven't changed since that
experience and forget about the
experience just overcome the emotion
because the memory without the emotional
charge is called wisdom and that's why
we're here so then you can look back at
the past and you can say wow I learned
something really great I'd never do that
again and by the way
when the experience finally lands in
your lap and you prove to yourself how
powerful you really are that you created
something by thought alone
and that event comes in a way that you
never expected that surprises you and
leaves No Doubt
that what you were doing inside of you
produced an effect outside of you and
you are exuberant and you feel worthy of
life and feel grateful to be alive that
you are in love with the moment
you will look back
at your entire past in that moment I
swear and you will not want to change
one thing in your past because it got
you to that present moment and that's
when it was all worth it that's when all
makes sense now you're free from the
past and now you're not you're not
thinking about the past any longer
you're believing in your future more
than you're believing in your past
you're more in love with your future
than you are with your past everybody
has done this
at some point in their life right where
they have to catch the thought
they have to catch their how they speak
the ACT they have to notice oh this is
that weird feeling again I'm not going
to just stay in this feeling can I
change it right so then if you remind
yourself every single day of who you no
longer want to be before you start your
day become conscious of your unconscious
self so conscious that you don't don't
go unconscious in your waking day the
next fundamental question is if your
personality creates your personal
reality
what thoughts do I want to fire and wire
in my brain and with attention with
presence and intention energy begin to
Fire and wire that thought if you can
fire and wire that thought you start
installing the neurological Hardware in
your brain keep doing it and start
acting acting like a software program it
becomes more automatic that's the new
voice in your head that says you can
it's possible or whatever and then
how are you going to behave in the zoom
meeting how are you going to behave with
your children how are you going to
behave with your ex how are you going to
be today when you open your eyes now
here's the cool part and you know this
the act of closing your eyes and
mentally rehearsing
who you're going to be planning your
actions in the day
mental rehearsal
shows that you could actually install
the neurological Hardware in your brain
to look like you already did it or it
already happened now the brain is no
longer a record of the past it now
becomes a map to the Future okay we've
all rehearsed something in our life and
our minds over and over again keep doing
it keep rehearsing it keep reviewing it
and it'll start to become more automatic
and you could actually program a person
then to behave as a happy person no
magic there you install the circuits now
here's the hardest part
can you teach your body emotionally
what that future would feel like before
it happens in other words don't wait for
your healing to feel gratitude don't
wait for your new relationship to feel
love don't wait for the mystical moment
to feel awe that's kind of the old model
of reality of cause and effect let's
wait for something out there to happen
to take away this emptiness this guilt
this lack the suffering whatever what if
I could condition my body emotionally
into the future so then we started
studying not only brain coherence but we
started studying heart coherence could a
person trade resentment and watch their
heart beat in a really irregular fashion
to a more coherent fashion where when
they're feeling gratitude when they're
feeling inspiration when they're feeling
love could they practice that enough
times so much so
they can condition their body into the
emotion of the future now here's the
cool part about that
our research shows you could absolutely
do that and do it so well that you feel
like the future that you're in wanting
to experience has already happened and
when it feels like it's already happened
you feel less separate from it which
means you're no longer looking for it
why would you look for it if you feel
like it's already happened now
to become familiar with the old self and
then fire and wire and condition the
body emotionally and chemically and
become familiar with the new self if
you're truly in the experiment of life
and I truly change my personality
there should be some evidence in my
world that there's been some change
either in my body in in my life in some
way and literally
their biology changes their their their
immune system changes they're we've
we've isolated thousands of metabolites
that show that that there's a
flourishing going on in the body the
body's responding it's believing
emotionally that it's living in a
different environment that's that's the
key your personality creates your
personal reality and your personality is
made up of how you think
how you act and how you feel so the
present personality who's listening to
this little video has created the
present personal reality called your
life
which means then if you wanted to create
a new personal reality a new life you
would have to change your personality
that means you'd have to start thinking
about what you've been thinking about
and change it it means you'd have to
become aware of your unconscious habits
and behaviors and modify them and you'd
have to look at certain emotions that
keep you connected to experiences in the
past and decide do these emotions belong
in your future
the beauty behind this is is that when
you begin to change how you think how
you act and how you feel you should
begin to see changes in your life and I
recommend that you try it out the
majority of our thoughts and feelings
are connected to our sexuality
to our victimization our guilt our
suffering or shame or unworthiness or
self-doubt or our importance our control
our fear our anger our frustration our
hatred our judgment those are those are
the first three hormonal centers in the
body and and those first three centers
have everything to do with survival and
those centers are energy consumers
orgasm digestion stress is a lot of
energy that that we're drawing from our
very vital life force yes a resource of
light and information and we're turning
it into chemistry and we're literally
robbing the body's energy right so so
then living like that for the short term
is okay because the body can move back
to homeostasis and then restore itself
but
when we're overdoing that consistently
then there's no energy for growth and
repair there's because you're living
constantly in survival so again you can
eat all the right food you can do all
the right things but if you're living in
anxiety and fear and you're viewing your
world from the worst case scenario that
could possibly happen because that's
what you do in survival there's no
energy for growth and repair there's no
energy for healing so the majority of
our thoughts are signaling certain
circuits in the brain that signal
another part of the brain limit brain to
make what's called a neuropeptide
neuropeptides are chemical Messengers
that signal hormonal centers so now
you're taking thought and you're storing
it as energy in these energy centers and
and if you're living in survival why
would you open your heart it's just not
a time to open your heart I mean if
you're getting chased by T-Rex it's not
a time to meditate it's not a time to
learn it's not a time to connect it's
not a time to communicate it's not a
time to sit down and go within it's not
a time to be vulnerable so think about
this
if you spend the majority of your day
focusing on matter
focusing on everything in this
three-dimensional world that's made of
material things it begs the question how
much of your time and your attention do
you put on that unified field that
invisible field of information that
exists beyond space and time and just
like when you're unaware of your nose it
doesn't exist and the moment you become
aware of it it exists
the quantum field is exactly the same
way if you put very little attention on
it in your waking day then it doesn't
exist for you but the moment you begin
to become aware of it the moment you
begin to pay attention to it the moment
you begin to stay present with it and to
experience it moment after moment and
where you place your attention as you
learned is where you place your energy
and where you place your attention
causes things to expand the moment you
begin to experience it not with your
senses you experience this
three-dimensional reality with your
senses but you experience it with your
Consciousness and with your awareness
the moment you become pure Consciousness
is the moment you make contact with that
unified field and so we now know
the techniques and the tools to get
people Beyond themselves and in fact we
know that after thousands and thousands
and thousands of brain scans that you're
at your absolute best when you get
Beyond yourself when you take your
attention off your body
when you take your attention off your
identity that's connected to people in
your life the things you own objects you
own places you have to go in time itself
the moment you become nobody no one no
thing no where in no time that is the
moment you become pure Consciousness and
that's the moment you begin to connect
to that field of possibilities called
the unified field or the quantum field
and that field in this invisible field
of information that exists Beyond this
space and time and independent of the
color of your skin your gender your diet
your sexual preference independent of
your profession your class
independent of all those things that
create separation
that every human being has access to it
I believe that if you can get two out of
those three in order if there's physical
stress emotional stress and chemical
stress then there's got to be physical
balance chemical balance and emotional
balance so let's just say you take all
your vitamins you take your drugs you do
your Pilates you do your core power you
know you you know get massage
acupuncture Chiropractic you run you
know all the things but you're still in
a toxic environment where you're
responding and reacting to the same
conditions emotionally well your body is
going to stay in the past because the
emotion is keeping you connected to the
past so what happens then
this happens numerous times and and the
people that do come to our work the
chemo didn't work
the surgery didn't work the radiation
didn't work the vegan diet didn't work
the ketogenic diet didn't work the yoga
didn't work nothing was working and so
then this is a point where the person
says I nothing outside of me
is changing what's inside of me and we
just had a cancer researcher on the
stage with Stage fat it had stage four a
stage four sarcoma in her uterus that
metastasized everywhere there's no
evidence of her disease in her body any
longer now
do I do I appreciate medicine do I
appreciate appreciate pharmacology yes I
do and I think for for acute uh uh
health conditions that medicine has a
really great handle on acute and crisis
situations when it comes to Chronic
health conditions
chronic health conditions require a
lifestyle change period you got to make
different choices if you truly want to
do it so
100 years ago 75 years ago you got
diagnosed with a health condition you
went to the doctor and she said or he
said you need this organ takened out
taken out you need this type of
treatment and I'm the authority you have
no access to the information that I have
so just do what I tell you and
everybody's signed and informed consent
and if my gallbladder is not going to
take that out if my uterus isn't good
take that out to take out whatever you
want
so then fast forward to today you get a
diagnosis what happens now
people go oh goodness um thanks for the
diagnosis then they go home and they
research everything about the health
condition why because information is
available now through technology so they
go back to their doctor and they say
gosh you know I want to try this other
treatment I want to try this alternative
thing and the doctor either says I don't
know anything about that or that's trash
and the person now looks squarely at the
doctor and the eye and says time to find
the new doctor in other words people do
the best when they feel good about the
care the health care that they're
choosing right so they're taking their
power back now to be able to say maybe
there is another way so the pharmacology
that we use when we're altered either
with anxiety or depression or cyclic
mood patterns or whatever it is is an
attempt to create chemical balance in
the body however if you're still
reacting to your ex in the same exact
way are you still
always predicting the worst thing that
could happen to you in your future and
embracing the emotion of that event
you're conditioning your body into
anxiety and you'll have a panic attack
and and and yes the the pharmacology
will help to create more balance but
your response and reaction to the
environment somehow
causes you to become dependent on that
exogenous substance now I don't have a
problem with that because everybody's at
their own point in evolution my mother
just listened to anything the doctor
said even when I said to her mom your
blood pressure is up because of stock
market she didn't want to hear that she
didn't think that she had to go to the
doctor through all these tests and all
this stuff and of course that's what it
turned out to be so
there's a greater listening that's
happening in the world now because of
information that that it's the four
minute mind that person that had the
sarcoma that stood on the stage was a
cancer researcher that told her story
that's the four minute mile I'm watching
1500 people in the audience leaning in
they're witnessing truth right in front
of them this is now they're conscious
that there's another possibility that
they were unconscious of and she doesn't
look vegan and she doesn't look slim and
she doesn't look young and buffed and
like a movie star she just looks like a
person a normal person and invariably
somebody in the audience
listening to truth because she's
speaking truth right now
telling her story about how hard it was
to overcome herself how hard it was to
overcome her body when she was in pain
and she didn't feel like doing the work
she did it anyway to overcome her doubt
to overcome her fear to overcome all of
those things and and believe in a future
that she can't see or experience with
her senses yet but truly understands the
science of how
that takes place once you understand the
what and why
the how becomes easier so we use science
as the Contemporary language to
demystify the process of personal change
and transformation it is the language
that we use that is that that doesn't
exclude anybody we don't talk tradition
we don't talk religion we don't talk
culture we don't talk spirituality
because that's going to divide the
audience so we create the scientific
model that's the first point learn it be
present with it but the next step is you
got to be able to teach it back so in
our audiences when we explain things and
we're combining quantum physics with
neuroscience and all neuroendocrinology
and all that stuff
once the person I finish the concept
you're gonna have to turn to Jonathan
and say okay let me just explain this
because I got a fire and wire this in my
brain I gotta understand what I'm doing
and why I'm doing it and nothing left to
conjecture nothing left to Superstition
nothing left the Dogma you understand
exactly what you're doing and why and
when you understand the meaning behind
it your prefrontal cortex turns on and
when it does the PowerHouse turns on and
you can get an ice bath and know nothing
about it the benefits of an ice bath get
an ice bath and you could really have a
really bad response you can get some
knowledge about what to do when you're
in the ice bath and the value of it and
once you understand that and you get in
the ice bath you will actually have
positive effects on your immune system
where when you didn't know what you were
doing and assigned meaning to it you had
a negative effect so so the person then
who's who has the intention
and the understanding and we set up the
conditions in the environment we give
them numerous opportunities
to get Beyond themselves numerous
opportunities to practice and evolve
their experience our research shows that
if you do that for seven days
the number of metabolic change
metabolites from the cell thousands of
metabolites that are being released in
the brain and body
suggests that the person is literally
their bodies believing they're living in
a different environment now here's the
weird part they're in a ballroom there's
nothing really amazing happening in a
ballroom I've been to thousands of
ballrooms they all look the same and yet
the body's looking like it's in a very
enriched environment it's looking like
it's in a different place so when you
have evidence and testimony
and you have evidence in scientific
measurements I think evidence all of a
sudden becomes the loudest voice and it
only takes one person or two people to
break that four minute mile and then all
of a sudden just like an infection
spreads amongst the community and
creates disease all of a sudden you see
health and wellness become as infectious
as disease there's a dramatic
transformation in biology so now that
that's possible now that people are
aware of that possibility
now it's in their Consciousness and
Consciousness is awareness and
information allows us to become aware of
what we were unaware of and that's what
that's that's what life is about to ex
to to evolve our experiences and and
some of those people are dependent on
Pharmaceuticals independent and I never
say stop taking anything
I'll say I always say keep going to your
doctor keep getting the scans keep
getting the tests you need feedback to
let you know what you're doing is
correct and and then make another choice
if it isn't but a lot of people actually
cross that River and wind up on the
other side and those are the people that
we're studying because those their blood
is Rich with a lot of information that
suggests that that there's a very
different experience going on inwardly
if you keep firing and wiring the same
thoughts in your mind that are related
to complaining and blaming and making
excuses and feeling sorry for yourself
and judging other people
um nerve cells that fire together wire
together you'll develop a very very
complex neurological Network that you
installed and keep doing it it becomes
so automatic it becomes unconscious
those thoughts for the most part are
slipping by people's awareness unnoticed
unchecked and every thought has a
chemical associated with it so
the moment the person begins to review
the problems in their life and those
problems are connected to certain people
and certain objects of certain
conditions at certain times and places
the moment they start thinking of their
problems they're thinking in the past
because the brain literally is a record
of the past and every one of those
problems has an emotion associated with
it so the moment they recall the problem
they feel the emotion of sadness or
guilt or shame or unworthiness now the
bodies in the past so then
if you begin to weigh the number of
times
people unconsciously do that in their
waking day they may have the best
visualization meditation rehearsal in
the morning and start out with really
good intentions
but that's 45 minutes or a half an hour
weighed against the other 16 or 15 hours
of their day where they're back to their
old self and so
the thinking positively is have no
effect on the body because it's it's a
small portion of what the person is
doing on a regular basis so the process
of change
there's an equal component of unlearning
there's an equal component of becoming
conscious of your unconscious thoughts
becoming aware of your automatic habits
and behaviors even how you speak and
sensing and noticing the emotions that
you feel that have become so familiar to
you on a regular basis
that it feels like you and the moment
you stop doing that you got to get ready
because it's gonna feel uncomfortable
it's going to feel unfamiliar it's not
going to feel like you anymore and many
people will go back to suffering and
complaining because at least they know
how they feel and they're back in the
Gnomes so so this is such an important
concept because
um this explains why people when they
they do the work and they don't notice
the results they get up from their
meditations
believing in their future less
instead of doing their meditations and
getting up and believing in their future
more right and so the reality is yes it
takes
equal amount of firing and wiring and
equal amount of emotional conditioning
to condition the body to the future but
you have to retire the personality of
the past and you got to stay so
conscious of your unconscious self that
you don't go unconscious
in your waking day and that's being in
that River of change and it takes a lot
of energy a lot of awareness to do it if
you think about great leaders in history
that change the course of many different
cultures uh what they did that was so
important is they had a vision of that
future
and they were able to have other people
come out of their resting emotional
state uh and begin to see that Vision
that they were seeing and move them into
an elevated emotional state and when
they changed their energy those people
could share that same vision well if you
combine a clear intention in an elevated
emotion those two ingredients change
people's state of being now the person
is just moved biologically from living
in the past to living in a new future in
the present moment and that's what
caused millions of people to begin to
make different choices to behave
differently to do different things and
if you get enough people doing that
because of mirror neurons everybody's
observing everybody do it and you create
a collective Consciousness and great
leaders have the ability to
based on core principles whether it's
Justice or Freedom or equality to have
people see that same vision and then
move them out of their resting state
into an elevated emotion and then when
they do that properly those people can
see that Vision if you can't change a
person's energy
they'll never see that Vision because
they'll be viewing the future through
the lens of the past the emotions of the
past and so great leaders have the
ability to to have people begin to see
the same vision I want to show you what
it looks like
when you learn something new you have a
hundred billion neurons in your brain
a hundred billion neurons
the number of connections you have in
one neuron is between ten thousand and
forty thousand connections if you took
100
5
000 Miles High that's the distance from
Los Angeles to London
if you took a scoop of gray matter the
size of a grain of sand you would have a
hundred thousand neurons in it with over
a billion connections now
I'll stop right after this slide
learning is making new synaptic
connections every time you learn
something new this is what's happening
in your brain geniuses
if you learned one bit of information
today
your brain did this
boom that's learning
physical evidence as a result of your
interaction in the environment
every time you learn something in your
brain there's a physical change that
takes place and learning is making new
connections
are you with me
this is how fast it happens too
that's learning if you learn anything
this week you've made a footprint if
learning is making new synaptic
connections
then if you keep firing the same
thoughts over and over again you're
going to wire them in your brain
so then if learning is making new
synaptic connections then remembering is
maintaining them
and all of a sudden they develop a
long-term relationship and just like any
relationship the more you communicate
the more they connect and neurons are
exactly the same way
now as you begin to learn information
neurons tend to assemble themselves into
networks or what's called neural
networks and neural networks are just
gangs of neurons that have fired and
wired together to form a community of
neurosynaptic connections that's related
to a thought a skill a habit a behavior
a concept
and neural networks are automatic
programs you have a neural network to
brush your teeth to put on makeup to
speak a language to walk
all of a sudden those neurons then form
a hardware circuitry but if you keep
repeating it the hardware becomes a
software program and it becomes
automatic people think that they want
certain things because they're
experiencing lack
and and so they have to go about
becoming
the very person so then if we reframe it
and you say oh I really want to be
wealthy I want all my needs met and I'll
say really why you want to be wealthy
and they'll say because I want freedom
I'd say okay let's focus on freedom
so now the person understands the
sponsoring thought or the emotion why
would you wait for your wealth to feel
free that's the Newtonian model of
reality of cause and effect waiting for
someone or something out there to take
away this emptiness or lack and what if
I'm feeling this emotion this emotion is
influencing certain thoughts and how I
think and feel creates my life if I'm
living in lack I'm not going to create
anything new
but if I say to you hey when you become
that person
once you become it then your your
reality is going to reorganize itself
instead of living by cause and effect
let's teach you how to cause an effect
so then the person then is no longer
interested in getting something in their
environment when they realize it's about
who they become
and all of a sudden now the emphasis or
the interest is in becoming that person
and we have a week with those people and
I want them to walk as it sit as it
stand as lay down and I said I want them
to get in the habit of walking from
their room to the ballroom it's become
the new habit that's why when we do our
work you're we're doing sitting
meditations we're doing standing and
walking meditations we're doing lying
down meditations I want it to become a
new habit I want them to become that
person experience enriches the brain now
you're laying down circuits for
something that has nothing to do with
the material world and that experience
produces an emotion but the emotion is
not going to be guilt or shame or
unworthiness or fear the emotions are
going to be ecstasy or Bliss and the
stronger the emotion you feel the more
you're going to be paying attention to
those pictures in your mind and
literally you're going to begin to
rewire your brain for the mystical and
when you open your eyes and you come
back to your senses you're going to see
a broader spectrum of reality you're
going to begin to see what has always
existed but you didn't have the circuits
in place to experience them because we
don't see things how they are we see
things how we are so now the person all
of a sudden opens their eyes and I've
had this happen you see colors and light
like you've never seen before you hear
everything's melodious everything's
unified so smell The Taste the feeling
of everything is just enhanced and we're
here
in three-dimensional reality for that
I mean we're here to really experience
life fully I mean that's why I'm here
that I'm not going to be guilty I'm not
going to be sad I mean we how many times
have we done that I mean that mystical
moment um when you have that experience
and you begin to perceive a whole in a
whole different way
uh and and you connected to that
intelligence uh you will see that that
energy that intelligence and every human
being and everything around you and
you'll feel more connected and less
separate and I think that's uh and I
think that's why we're here 86 of the
people in the Western World the first
thing they do when they wake up in the
morning is grab their cell phone that's
almost nine out of ten people so more
than likely there's a good percentage of
people that are watching this podcast or
listening to it that do that and when
they reach for their cell phone and they
look through their Facebook and their
Instagram and their Tick Tock and their
emails and their uh Twitter and do all
of that they're connecting to everything
that's known in their life they're
actually making sure that they're
connected in a certain way
in place of that
you can still do that but before you
grab unconsciously for your phone and
start changing your chemicals in your
body it would be such a great idea to
sit down and before you start your day
just review the thoughts you don't want
to think
review the behaviors you really want to
change about yourself just review them
just go over them in your mind re review
the emotions that you feel the most in a
day and just remember that those
emotions aren't loving to you just just
review them in the beginning just so
that you're aware of them have to change
you'll start becoming aware of them and
when once you can observe them you're no
longer the program once you're conscious
of them you're no longer unconscious
right you're out of the program
before you start the day ask yourself
what how do I want to think today how do
I want to feel how do I want to behave I
mean what would greatness look like what
would love look like today what could I
do
that would be really cool for me at the
end of the day say wow so I had a good
day today what what would make me feel
that way and if you can't find an answer
to that start reading who reads anymore
read a book I read so many books a week
I know I'm that way too so read
something about you want to be wealthy
read a book about someone who became
wealthy and get get real and realize
they may have failed 50 times before
they actually pulled it off or what were
their characteristics what were their
traits What made them it's not wasn't
about their wealth it was about who they
became that's the key right so so so
fill your brain with a little knowledge
and then just start asking yourself
what's the greatest expression of myself
that I can be today and and and rehearse
it rehearse how you're going to be and
and then if if it leads to a different
Choice that's the unknown and just know
that it's not going to be predictable
it's going to be a little uncomfortable
that's where the magic happens if you
can stay relaxed and awake in the
unknown
things get pretty exciting when you're
back to the known you're back to the
familiar don't expect anything to change
in your life and if you say it's that
person or that circumstance
ah you default and went back to the
program of the victim allowing your
outer environment controlling your
thoughts and feelings if you truly do
this well
this is what I discovered
if I truly feel the feelings of my
future before they occur and I live in
that state I'm no longer looking for it
to happen how could I look for it if I
feel like it already has right so I try
to stay in that state because then I
don't then I'm not separate from it and
that tends to be when the magic happens
there there's no control anymore there's
no predicting there's no perfectionism
there's none of all there is is just
kind of an experiment like I'm
experimenting to see if I changed my
thoughts and feelings if my life will
change and that should be the experiment
everybody has and and and do it with
with curiosity and do it with just
seeing if if the experiment works if it
doesn't change something else about
yourself well I think we've been
programmed quite a bit uh in with our
relationship with money and we have a
relationship with everything known in
our environment you have a relationship
a neurological Network in your brain to
for your parents for your cell phone for
your computer where you live where
you've lived in the past what you're
going to do tomorrow
that for the most part the brain is a
reflection of everything that we know
right so along with that is our
relationship with money and I I feel
like I have a really good relationship
with money because I work on having a
really good relationship with everything
in my life did you always have a good
relationship I think so I think so I've
never really lived in lack that just
wasn't part of it even when I went to
college and I had to take out student
loans and stuff I always figured out a
way to always be a little bit ahead of
the curve and so so
let's back up and just look at how
people form beliefs because yes most
beliefs are created from past
experiences right so uh children uh when
they're uh in their early ages their
brain waves are very slow like their
brain waves are in Alpha when they're
like seven to twelve they're in Theta
when they're like two to six years old
and and they're in Delta like when
they're when they're you know newborn to
two years old and so these brainwave
States uh are states that were really
suggestible to information so when we
hear information we believe it and we
accept it we believe it we surrender to
it as if it's the truth without
analyzing it because there's no
analytical facilities yet right the
analytical mind starts around 12 or so 7
to 12 and that analytical mind is
actually what creates a barrier between
the conscious mind and the subconscious
mind so 412 roughly what we see how how
we model our parents Behavior it's all
being programmed subconsciously right
and so so that's really really important
because if you heard money is the root
of all evil
uh money is bad only certain people are
allowed to make money you have to work
hard to make money this is how you got
to do it and
that becomes the foundations
subconsciously like let's like write
recording an audio file you just keep
recording that audio file it becomes a
subconscious program right so a lot of
people have a relationship with money
based on either what they've been told
or what they've experienced in their
outer environment right so
so then we gain information from our
environment and the stronger the emotion
we feel from experiences in our lives
the more altered we feel inside of us
the more the brain freezes a frame and
takes a picture and that snapshot is
called the memory So based on an emotion
based on emotion the emotion Alters our
internal state so you're going along as
Lewis feeling really good and all of a
sudden you have this trauma you have
this crisis you have this shock and all
of a sudden you have this dramatic
change in your internal State and your
senses get heightened and then you
freeze the frame and you associate this
internal state with whatever it is
that's causing it right and that's how
we create long-term memories what's
emerging in the world now because of
information
information is teaching people that
there are other possibilities that they
were unconscious to and you don't need
an authority any longer you don't need a
priest you don't need a governor you
don't need a teacher you don't need a
doctor to gain information any longer
information is available but the
question is
what will you do with it so if you give
people sound scientific information and
science is the language of mysticism and
you combine quantum physics with
neuroscience and neuroendocrinology and
psychon or immunology and epigenetics
and electromagnetism and make it simple
and don't talk about tradition or
religion or culture that's going to
divide it on the audience but bring a
model of Science in
a person can reason and understand what
they're doing with that information
and why they're doing it then the side
effect of how they're doing it is going
to get easier and now the application
becomes essential so what we're seeing
is this the emergent Consciousness where
people are taking their power back
and not relying on anyone or anything
for their own personal change or
transformation and I think that when you
get enough people doing it emergence in
biology is a group of birds all moving
in the same direction of school of fish
all moving the appearance is a larger
organism they're behaving in the exact
same way there's no leader when you
study that in biology everybody's
leading so how are we going to change
the world it's not one person not one
Consciousness it's a collective
Consciousness and the research says that
Collective networks of observers
determine reality get enough people
believing in possibility sooner or later
someone's going to run into that
experience and you need one once you
know it's possible then other people
will start doing it as well just like
the four minute mile so
so in the world right now I think we're
seeing it breaking down
of so many conventions where whether
it's religion or medicine or the
environment there's journalism
everything's falling apart right now
because it can't sustain itself because
no organisms in nature live in this kind
of abusive competition we organisms
survive in cooperation and connection
and communion
keep people in fear
keep them angry keep them in pain keep
them all those survival emotions you'll
never have Community you bring people
into an elevated emotional state
something innate in the human species
says we're empathic to one another and
we celebrate one another we want to get
along with one another we want to
cooperate we want to resolve issues
together that's that's who we are when
we're not living in stress and survival
the hormones of stress push the genetic
buttons that create disease if you can
turn on the stress response just by
thought alone
your thoughts could make you sick and if
your thoughts could make you sick is it
possible that your thoughts could make
you well so they began to realize that
oh my God the repetition of thinking and
feeling and feeling and thinking caused
me to feel guilt and I don't even know
it's guilt it just feels like me it's
just I'm used to the same chemical
continuity now the moment they decided
to change anytime you decide to change
and change anything about yourself get
ready because it's going to feel
uncomfortable you're going to leave The
Gnome yeah you're gonna leave the
familiar and you're gonna step into the
unknown even if the familiar is
uncomfortable and painful right you
still can be painful leaving the pain
right because some people are super
happy being unhappy right so then they
would rather cling to their suffering
than take a chance in possibility so
these people said I really have nothing
to lose right
so then they said I'm willing to be
uncomfortable and be in the unknown and
it turns out that's the perfect place to
create from so when the body is
conditioned to become the mind then to
change is to be greater than the body
right because we become greater than the
body well that's a whole nother
conversation but let me finish this okay
so the third thing they said was
okay so now that I know that I got to
break the habit of being myself and I
can't mismanage my thoughts and feelings
I got to change how I act I gotta Watch
How I speak I gotta become conscious of
how unconscious I am because 95 percent
of Who We Are by the time we're 35 years
old it's a set of memorized behaviors
like a computer program emotional
reactions unconscious beliefs and
perceptions so the first step to change
is to become conscious of how you think
to notice how you act to pay attention
to how you feel and the act of observing
those states of Mind and Body separates
you from that program now you're you're
you're the Consciousness observing that
program it turns out the more conscious
you become of how unconscious you are
you know lighting a match in a dark
place
that first step creates enormous amounts
of Chaos in the brain and body and it's
disturbing so people just go back to the
same addiction the same emotion the same
problem just feels better no that feels
familiar so they said okay now I'm not
going to change I gotta reinvent myself
now this is really important because
they started sitting down and thinking
Okay who in history do I admire we're
great people role models that I can
follow what are the qualities and
characteristics that they have how am I
going to change you know these are what
we call frontal lobe questions the
creative center of the brain switch is
on an emotional Center settles down
so then they started thinking
how would I have to be in a new life if
I was really going to heal what would I
have to change about myself
now there's this interesting phenomenon
that if you close your eyes and you
begin to think about doing something
you're an athlete you understand this if
you're a background in football and you
are running a pattern or you are doing
something you would rehearse it in your
mind turns out
that the act of mentally rehearsing
something when you're truly present
your brain does not know the difference
between what's going on out there and
what's going on in here in fact your
brain will begin to look like you've
been doing it for the last five days and
you've never run the course so now your
brain is no longer a record of the past
because typically it is now it's a map
to the Future so now you're priming your
brain so that became the very platform
you know experiments with piano players
you know you take a group of people that
never played the piano before you divide
them into two different categories
I think one group of people you teach
them one-handed scales and chords you do
a brain scan on them they come in
practice for two hours a day for five
days at the end of five days if you
rescan the brain they grow new circuits
on the opposite side of the brain
nothing magical there you learn
something new learning's making new
connections get some instruction you get
instruction you get your body involved
get your body involved you're gonna have
an experience experience in which is the
brain pay attention to what you're doing
you got to pay attention and repeat it
firing and wiring hearing with simple
new circuits you can take the other
group of people have them come for two
hours a day for five days do a brain
scan before the brain scan after have
them close their eyes and mentally
rehearse playing those scales and chords
at the end of five days they'll grow the
same amount of circuits and their brain
as the people who actually physically
demonstrated the action what does that
mean it means not only they change their
brain by thinking differently but their
brain looks like they've been playing
the piano for five days now set them in
front of a piano never play the piano
before they'll play those scales and
chords because their brain is wired to
play it so now the act of rehearsing who
they're going to be
what are the qualities I'm beginning to
get in this creative state began to lay
down the circuits of a new personality
and a new personality is connected to a
new personal reality so the next
question is does that change the body
take a group of men have them do
one-handed
curls in their mind and bring an
emotional component like stronger harder
more intense one hour a day for two
weeks at the end of two weeks 13.5
increase in muscle strength wow never
lifted away now their body is changing
by thought Allah so these people began
to reprogram their brain and body
and all of a sudden they began to act
differently why because they installed
the circuits they began to think
differently of course they began to feel
differently they they were no longer
feeling pain they're actually liking
themselves right so that if they're
living by a different emotion and
they're they're feeling an elevated
emotion before their healing before they
were healed they're not waiting for
their healing to feel Joy and gratitude
they're feeling gratitude and joy now
their bodies believing that it's healed
because the body's feeling the emotion
ahead of the experience if the
environment signals the Gene and the end
product of an experience in the
environment is emotion you're signaling
the gene ahead of the environment and
what do genes do genes make proteins or
what are proteins responsible the
structure and function of the body now
you're literally becoming somebody else
and now you're turning down the genes
for disease and you're turning up these
other genes so
I started to realize that this
reinvention process is exactly what
we've always done it's just that we get
complacent in certain areas of our life
and we stop let's demystify the present
moment okay people wake up in the
morning and they they think about their
problems and those problems or memories
that are etched in their brain that are
connected to certain people and objects
at certain times and places the moment
they wake up in the morning and they
start thinking of the problems they're
thinking in the past
okay now every one of those problems has
an emotion associated with it so when
they feel unhappy when they feel bitter
when they feel fearful now their bodies
in the past thoughts are the language of
the brain feelings of the language of
the body thought and a feeling image and
emotion stimulus and response you're
conditioning the body to be the mind of
that emotion subconsciously now the body
is believing it's living in the same
past experience 24 hours a day seven
days a week 365 days a year why because
the body's so objective it doesn't know
the difference between the real life
experience that's creating that emotion
and the emotion that person is creating
important body doesn't know the
difference and so what would the
environment signals the gene that's
epigenetics the end product from an
experience in the environment is an
emotion the person's signaling the same
genes in the same way and genes make
proteins and proteins are responsible
for the structure and function of your
body and the expression of proteins as
expression of life and now the person is
actually headed for a genetic Destiny
and when people labor
for the present moment
and they take their attention off of
their body off of all the people in
their life all of the objects they own
their cell phone their computer their
car their house they're no longer
identifying with where they're sitting
where they need to be where they live
where they've lived in the past where
they need to go and they're not thinking
about the predictable future of the
familiar past
they're dissociating from everything
physical and material everything known
that is the exact moment we call getting
Beyond yourself okay now
when we're in that place then at the
beginning it's uncomfortable because
where survival is the unknown you better
chances of survival and running from the
unknown but that unknown is the perfect
place to create from so in the process
no different than any rehab in our first
two days of our event really people are
they're basically they're basically
rehabbing from their emotional states
and their habits and they're sitting in
the presence of that discomfort right
and the discomfort is because the body
is leaving the known but but but
if the body has been conditioned to be
the mind the moment you take it outside
of its familiar territory it's going to
start telling you Ed why don't you quit
you know you're not really good at this
you know you're more of a physical
person you don't really want to do this
you're not very this or very fat and
most people just get up on their do
their meditation they believe that
thought as if it's true now the question
is what's on the other side of that
thought can you sit there long enough
till that's no longer the thought you
accept believe and surrender to
well then wow the next question inside
of that thought what is the other what's
on the other side of that familiar
emotion can I sit and work with my body
and settle it down stay
you stay I'm gonna feed you you're not
gonna die from this your bladder's not
going to explode you're not going to go
crazy and you work with catching those
thoughts it's called metacognition if
you're in that 95 of programming where
you're unconscious
and the first step to change is becoming
conscious of your unconscious thoughts
you're so conscious that you would never
go unconscious or let that thought slip
by you unnoticed I want to understand so
you're saying the awareness of the
thought being conscious of the thought
has it somehow lose its power over you
exactly exactly because just because you
have a thought doesn't mean it's true
and if you're left alone to yourself
you'll start believing every thought you
think and that's the problem so then the
majority of people's thoughts then are
based on what they perceive about
themselves from their past or their life
right and if you catch yourself
complaining and blaming and making
excuses and judging someone else and you
say I want to be a happy person well a
happy person would never do that would
make them unhappy if you notice that
you've been feeling guilty for the last
20 years you didn't know it was guilt
because it just felt like you and you
want to feel Joy well if you can feel
Joy it should tell us volumes about what
you've been practicing doing right so
then most people give up because
they they don't know that there's
anything on the other side of it so then
the next question is
what thoughts do you want to fire and
wire in your brain well and with
attention and with intention
if you keep practicing firing wiring
those thoughts you start installing
Hardware do it enough times and it
becomes like a software program and now
that's the new voice you program in your
head that said I can do this I believe
in myself and you've created to an
extent a new personality which can
create a new personal reality now here
we go so then the next question is how
am I going to behave with my kids today
how am I going to be with my wife I'm
going to be with my partner I'm going to
be at work I might be on my zoom calls
I'm going to be by myself how am I going
to what what does greatness look like
what would love do today now it turns
out that if you close your eyes and you
start imagining doing that if you
rehearse how you're going to be in those
certain situations
the evidence without a doubt shows that
your brain will start to look like
through the mental rehearsal of the act
that you've already done it now you've
installed the hardware keep doing it it
becomes a software program and you'll
start acting like a happy person no
magic there if you don't have the
circuits you can't do it so the
rehearsal then
is actually changing the brain just by
thinking differently the brain looks
like the experience has already happened
now you have Hardware to use do it
enough times you get good at it becomes
more automatic now here's the hard part
can I teach my body emotionally
what my future will feel like before it
happens now this is really important
because there's a pandemic going on in
the world that has nothing to do with a
virus that has everything to do with
people's attention span and learning
people need a rush of dopamine in order
to catch their attention or a rush of
adrenaline to learn and so that they're
they're dependent on their outer
environment to regulate their emotional
state now this is different now now I'm
going to say to you
get in that beautiful heart of yours and
I want you to feel gratitude for the
event before it occurs well I can't feel
it because it hasn't happened yet that's
the conditioning that's the hypnosis
it's kind of crazy I think you I think
you know one of the most important
things is it's so much easier to forget
this information than to remember even
me you know I have to say to myself okay
Joe dispenza what do you know and take a
moment and just set down my cell phone
and disconnect from everything and
really have a thought like
and keep reconstructing the model in my
mind it's so important to do that
because if we understand the what and
the why and the how it gets easier then
we assign more meaning and more belief
and more intention behind it and
and if you have to say okay
okay if I'm living by these emotions
that are familiar to me and I'm
signaling the same genes in the same way
okay now I have to be conscious of not
feeling that way and you have to make a
different choice and the hardest part
about change is not making the same
choices you did the day before because
the moment
you decide to do something different
when you're making a choice it's going
to be uncomfortable you're going to
leave the known familiar world of the
familiar emotions and thoughts and
behaviors
the body is the unconscious mind is
going to want to return back to what it
knows because we trained it that way so
it's a retraining process so if the
person says okay if I can marry a clear
intention I gotta work on getting my
brain more coherent okay they got that
in the formula that'll be a good signal
out if I can slow my brain waves down I
can learn how to do that I can get
beyond my thinking analytical mind I can
enter the operating system of my
autonomic nervous system program that
okay if I can combine it with an
elevated emotion really practice trading
that that suffering or that pain for
something else yeah it may take me a
little bit to feel that emotion but I
think if I keep working at it I'll begin
to change my emotional state when I feel
that emotional state I'm not going to be
thinking about the past I'm going to be
thinking about the future so so the
thought and the feeling the stimulus in
response the image and the emotion is
conditioning body emotionally into the
future so the person says okay he said
or I read or someone else said the
environment signals the gene okay let me
write that down environment signals the
gene okay I remember that
the end product of an experience in the
environment is the emotion okay
um if I'm feeling gratitude
and gratitude's emotional signature
means I've just received something
favorable or something wonderful just
happened to me
if I can feel the emotion of gratitude
before the event occurs
then my body would be so objective that
it's living in that future I would begin
to change my gene expression and the
stronger the emotion I feel the more I'm
going to pay attention to the picture in
my mind that I'm going to be remembering
my future my brain and body are going to
look like the event has already occurred
before it happened and if genes make
proteins and proteins are responsible
for the structure and function of my
body and the expression of proteins is
the expression of life
then I'm going to keep signaling these
I'm going to keep knocking on the door
every day and I don't care if my life is
falling apart I'm not going to fall to
that familiar emotion I'm not going to
speak the same way I'm not going to
think the same way what thoughts do I
want to fire and wire in my brain and
with intention and attention I'm going
to keep reviewing them till it becomes
an automatic thought in my head like you
can
what how am I going to be today how am I
going to be with my family I'm going to
be in traffic I'm going to be with my
co-workers how am I going to be when I'm
alone
and you start rehearsing who you're
going to be the brain in the present
moment doesn't know the difference
between the outer world or the inner
world it's the brain what it's imagining
looks real and if we're present the
brain looks like you already did it
you're priming the brain it's no longer
on record of the past now you're it's a
map to the Future you're you're in place
keep practicing that rehearsal in your
mind it's going to become automatic and
you're going to start behaving like that
person then you said
can I teach my body emotionally what
this future feels like before it happens
if you could truly open your heart and
truly feel that elevated emotion if you
kept practicing that I promise you you
would feel more of that in your day and
less of the other place and meditation
means to become familiar with and how
you think how you act and how you feel
is your personality and your personality
creates your personal reality that's the
game right so when that occurs then it's
no longer about the past and what
happened to you and the story people
tell about that they're telling a story
of their future in fact they're more in
love with their future than they are
with their past their their they believe
in the future more than they believe in
their past and and I think that when we
believe in ourselves we believe in
possibilities and we believe in
possibilities we have to believe in
ourselves and showing up every day
means you must believe it's true when
you stop showing up then you don't
believe it's true any longer and and
enough people that have that kind of
conviction literally step into a new
body they step into a new a new life
they step into a new future and I I hope
um but that becomes the new normal
um and and you know research says that
Collective networks of observers
determine reality that's the latest
so we just got to make sure enough of us
are observing a different reality from
an elevated place of Union and
connection instead of Separation that's
that divides communities because of
survival and stress and that's a great
way to create polarity in the world and
the union of polarity takes place in the
heart and that's where it starts it
doesn't end there it just starts there
and when I see the heart and forming the
brain I saw two students that we grabbed
one was chasing a little child around a
one and a half year old child and he was
being challenged and the other guy was
working and Staffing and running around
and we got him in the chair and we said
okay let's let's get some Brandon
hardcoherence and you know we had 15 20
minutes to do with these guys and you
saw them way out of balance right and
just way out of bounds and all sudden
here comes that low frequency in the
heart boom like a big drum boom
boom all of a sudden you see that low
frequency the energy in the heart that's
only indigenous to the heart itself
starts rising and then all of a sudden
you see it rise and then you see the
sympathetic nervous system rise with it
so now we know they're totally relaxed
and they're totally awake and aware the
sympathetic nervous isn't working for an
arousal when you see that kind of
connection and you see someone be able
to change that
a matter of moments my I say they should
be able to do that with their eyes open
at any moment it should be such a skill
and that's that's when we we maintain
our energy and our power a good way to
see that is that everybody does it like
everybody does that all the time and
they would here's the problem all of
that is fine the problem is is that
they're looking
through the lens of the past that
reality they're they're seeing they're
seeing their future through the lens of
the past they can't see possibility
because they can't think greater than
how they feel or feelings have become
the means of thinking and if you believe
that your thoughts have anything to do
with your destiny then you're thinking
in the past because those emotions are
driving your thoughts and those emotions
are the familiar records of the past
right so now so let me just go one step
further so so that is
how people reaffirm themselves every
single day into a known identity and
let's just say the trauma or the
Betrayal or the loss or the shock or the
diagnosis was a profound moment that
created a strong emotion and that person
doesn't think that they have any control
of regulating and changing that emotion
because it's visceral it's somatic it's
real they feel it and that disturbance
that known they'd rather cling to that
pain they'd rather cling to that that
suffering the than to take a chance and
possibility to step outside the unknown
now the hardest part
I'm getting to time by the way the
hardest part about all of this
then is not making the same choices you
did the day before
so the moment you start to realize that
you complain that you blame that you
make excuses that you feel sorry for
yourself that you judge others that you
react emotionally to your spouse to your
ex to your co-workers to traffic the
moment you become conscious that you're
doing that and you say I'm gonna stop
well the body now the servant that is
now the mind that the servant is not a
master so now the body's cling to the
known and you say okay I'm not going to
complain I'm not going to suffer anymore
you make a different choice and the body
says well wait a second
Jonathan you've been doing that for 30
years so you just
watch so the body starts influencing the
mind it starts sending signals back to
the brain and says you can't do this
it's too hard start tomorrow it's your
mother's fault it's your culture's fault
it's it's this it's your past
and if you accept believe and surrender
to that thought
as if it's true without really having a
critical analysis of it it slips right
by your conscious mind and it causes you
to make the same choice that leads to
the same behavior that will reproduce
the same experience and there you are on
the couch feeling the same emotion and
you say this feels right well no that
feels familiar right so that's that's
how people live in the gnome they live
in the past so the predictable future
then is everybody gets up and routine
and they're on autopilot and they run
through a series of automatic behaviors
and if you do that enough time a habit
is a redundant set of automatic
unconscious thoughts behaviors and
emotions that's acquired through
repetition do it enough times the body
will now know how to do it better than
the conscious mind it becomes implicit
right so now most people lose their free
will
to a set of programs and their body's
dragging them into a predictable future
based on what they did in the past and
that predictable future is the known as
well so if the familiar past is the
known and the predictable future is the
known there's only one place left
where the unknown exists and that's
really that sweet spot of the generous
present moment and when we truly can
become relaxed and dial down
the stress hormones that cause us to
live in survival that causes us to try
to anticipate the worst case scenario
that remembers the past if we can work
with the body and be greater than the
body
to be greater than our attention on
every element in our environment and
truly labor for the present moment that
unknown which has been conditioned to
the into the human being to be a scary
place because in survival you run from
the unknown if you can teach people to
actually relax into the present moment
and relax into that place that's the
unknown that's where possibility exists
and we all do it
and getting to that elegant moment then
time tends to alter you think only 10
minutes went by about an hour and a half
went by and where were you well as your
brain waves slow down in this process
when you're in like a thinking
analytical place like we are right now
we're in these great bearing wave
patterns it's called you understand it's
beta brainless patterns but as you slow
your body down and starts moving to
Alpha time Alpha Waves tend to cause
time to seem a little bit more elongated
when you're in Theta which is when
you're half awake and you're half asleep
and you're relaxed and awake and that
level of theta time one moment seems
really long so you have an extension of
time and turns out that you can teach
people how to do this and when you do
their autonomic nervous system begins to
regulate back into order and stress is
autonomic dysregulation and all of a
sudden the person has a sense of energy
a sense of euphoria a sense of Freedom a
sense of clarity the brains we've
measured this their brains start firing
in more ordered more coherence that it
oscillates and synchronizes different
compartments of the brain or communities
of neurons are working together and you
start feeling more whole more like
yourself in the in the understanding of
yoga as an example
if you're truly really into the ACT
you forget about all your problems you
forget about all the things you got to
do you forget about what happened
yesterday breathing is away
to really change your brain waves as
we've studied this thousands of times
you slow your breathing down you slowing
your brain waves down you slow your
brain waves down and you stop analyzing
and thinking when do you over analyze
and overthink when you're in high high
high beta and when's that when you're
threatened when you feel danger when
when the stress hormones are running and
we've studied the brain when this
happens and when you're analyzing your
life within that disturbing emotion I
can guarantee you you're going to make
your brain worse in fact your thought of
the problem is actually producing the
very chemistry to arouse you further out
of balance so teaching people
how to find that generous present moment
and actually relax in the unknown and
dissociate from their body dissociate
from their environment and dissociate
from time the predictable future and the
familiar past causes them for some
reason to get a reboot in in their
nervous system and they think oh God it
must have been 10 minutes and oh my God
it was it was an hour and a half that
that to me
is taking all of your attention or
disinvesting all of your attention out
of this three-dimensional reality and
that's when the door to Creation or the
mystical moment really begins to happen
for people I mean if you think about the
illusion of three-dimensional reality
and and this hologram that were fooled
into our senses into this concept of
Separation there's me here and there's
you there and there's distance in space
and there's objects and there's things
in this three-dimensional reality causes
us to go from one point of awareness I'm
here to another point of awareness say
the front door and we have to move
through space and we move through space
it takes time right so anything that we
want in our lives takes time and energy
got to go to work
and you gotta you know you gotta do all
the things and then you gotta save money
and then you go buy the thing and that's
the rules of three-dimensional reality
the plane of demonstration means you got
to do something right so then there's me
here and then my dreams are way way out
there and I estimate how long it's going
to take for me to arrive at those
streams because we're playing by the
rules of three-dimensional reality and
we play by those rules
um
for the most part I'm gonna wait for the
experience to occur in order to have the
experience producing emotion and the
emotion is the chemical feedback as a
result of the event now there's nothing
wrong with this that's the game in in
three-dimensional world
if you're going to shorten the distance
between cause and effect between the
thought of something and the experience
of something you got to go to a
different set of rules and you have to
create from the quantum field now the
quantum field is an invisible field of
energy that exists Beyond this space and
time now this takes a little bit of
imagination because
if we don't have any space between us
then we're connected there's no
separation uh and and there's no time so
now when you go to the realm of a
Quantum the rules change because in the
quantum things are connected energy
connects things together
so then if you were able to create from
the field instead of from matter and
it's not matter that's emitting a field
it's the field that's actually creating
matter if we could change information in
the field we could change the Hologram
in three-dimensional reality and it
turns out you only need two things to do
that
yeah super coherent brain super
organized coherent brain and coherence
is a rhythm or an order so when the
brain is coherent it has a directive
it's an electrical charge it's the
signal we send out into the field we're
broadcasting information with our
thoughts
now most people who have been
conditioned and hypnotized into the
rules of three-dimensional reality
they're waiting for the experience to
happen to feel the emotion of the
experience to take away their lack or
separation like whatever it's abundance
it's love it's healing whatever it is
but in the quantum model
you have to combine that clear intention
with an elevated emotion and that takes
heart coherence so we've done extensive
studies in training our community
to begin to feel the emotion of the
event before it happens and people say
well I don't know how it would feel
because I haven't experienced it well
the answer is really simple
if you felt gratitude or you felt
appreciation or love for life or a joy
for existence
and you combine that clear intention
with an elevated emotion the heart
produces a magnetic field and that
magnetic field expands out and it
transcends the rules of space and time
when you feel whole when you feel this
elevated emotion you feel connected you
feel bonded and so when you feel the
emotion of your future
you're connecting to the energy of the
future and your body is so objective
it does not know the difference between
the real life experience that's creating
that emotion and the emotion that you're
creating by thought alone the body's
actually believing it's living in that
future reality in the present moment so
if the thought sends the signal out and
the feeling draws the event back and
your brain and hard coherence you got a
really powerful Wi-Fi signal
and when you begin to do this properly
you no longer have to go anywhere to get
anything in other words you're not
living by the rules of of cause and
effect you're living by the rules of
causing an effect you're producing an
outcome now here's the cool part if
there's a vibrational match between your
energy and you've really refined that
signal
and you can synchronize your energy you
start having synchronicities in your
life and you start getting Universal
science coming to you you have
opportunities you have synchronicities
serendipities coincidences and you're
not going anywhere to get it they're
coming to you now think about this if
you're connected to an invisible field
of energy that's the source of
everything physical and material if you
were Connected To Source why would you
go anywhere you wouldn't do that you
would say come to me right so so by
doing this properly
and causing an effect when you see
feedback in your life as the result of
what you're doing
you're going to pay attention to what
you did and you're going to do it again
now the cool part is is that once you
feel the excitement the inspiration The
Joy The Love For Life
that's actually reinforcing the feeling
that you've created with and if you
create again you refine the signal a bit
more you get more synchronicities no
more opportunities and the cool part
about our community
is that they're not saying oh God I have
to go create my life they're not saying
that they actually don't want to stop
doing it because they don't want those
they don't want the magic to end they
don't want those cool Quantum events
that are occurring in their life to stop
so it's not like I have to they're just
they're changing their energy and when
you change your energy you change your
life and I've been at this long enough
to tell you that nobody changes until
they change their energy and and and so
when you experiment with this as a as a
process and you learn a particular
formula and we've been we've been
refining this and studying it so much in
the last couple years
that the amount of coherence that we see
in some of our student Community is so
incredibly organized and not only
organized but the amount of energy in
the brain the amount of energy in the
heart is higher amplitude so no bigger
signal bigger Wi-Fi signal more
connection and so then you if you can
shorten the distance
between cause and effect
between the thought of what you want and
the experience of what you want
then you would start to master your life
and then you would start to see wow I
could actually if I if I could do this
what could I do next and and I'm happy
to say that you know people are doing it
pretty well ask yourself at the end of
your day I do this every day how'd I do
how'd I do today bro how'd you do just
do good where'd you fall from grace what
what what was it that caused you to go
unconscious
for the rest of the day like what was
that moment now if you're a student of
Life you'll begin to contemplate well it
was that person that said that thing
then I reacted or this I got this email
or things didn't go my way and I started
feeling angry or frustrated or fearful
the next time that happens how could I
involve my experience now you may have
to search for some answers of the best
model to build or you may actually have
a long contemplation and start to go God
the next time that happens I think I'm
gonna do this or I'm gonna do that or
I'm going to plan my behaviors and the
act of closing your eyes and rehearsing
what you're going to do
begins to install the neurological
Hardware in your brain to looks like you
already did it now the brain is no
longer a record of the past now it's a
map to the Future and if you keep
installing that Hardware the hardware
will become a software program which
means you'll just start acting like a
happy person why there's no magic there
you install the circuitry so
that's more important
than the news right it's more important
than answering any email or any text
it's more important than talking about
your past or some dinner if you can
begin to just think about how you're
going to do it differently that's the
building process neurologically already
so now you have to get conscious in
order to do that and it takes some time
it means you got to shut your cell phone
off you got to close your door you gotta
take a break from everything out there
and begin to practice and so by
experience then
you start noticing oh here it comes here
comes the frustration here comes the
fear and now we've given people the
tools to be able to self-regulate to
create brain and heart coherence and so
you see people say excuse me one minute
I just need a minute
it takes some breaths they get back in
they connect to the energy of their
future this is incidental compared to
where they're going so they don't fall
from grace they don't allow their energy
to drop and so yeah in the beginning it
takes a lot because it takes a lot of
energy and awareness to stay conscious
and not go unconscious but if you're
persistent and you're determined then
you're sincere you begin to figure it
out you begin to say I am not going to
give my power away to that person or
that circumstance when I can use it to
heal or to create a new future and so
people then won't excuse themselves and
say on a hard day yesterday at a fight
with my co-worker or my ex or and I
don't feel like doing the work well
that's the time they get back on the
horse yeah because because it's the it's
all of those times that we self-correct
those are the most valuable moments thus
people who have had
profoundly transcendental experiences
where they we say got lit up they
connected and their brain goes into very
very high coherent States and super
gamma patterns that are way outside of
normal and they have a transcendental
downloader connection that's mystical
they look back at their entire life
they don't want to change one thing in
their past because it got them to that
moment that's the moment the past no
longer exists now by the same means they
look back at their past and they see all
those tough moments where they overcame
themselves and they fall in love with
that person they don't look at the good
meditations or the things that went well
they look they know that it was those
moments that got them to this moment and
I I think then that's when they begin to
understand that that all of the hard
work
all the effort in who we become makes no
one can take that away from us so then
once we arrive at that level and we
experience whatever the dream is or
whatever we create the next thing is do
it until you've fully enjoy it and then
when it gets boring or predictable let's
go again let's do something else yeah
and I think that's Evolution meditation
the actual translation of the word
meditation means to become familiar with
so the first thing you have to do is you
have to become conscious of your
unconscious thoughts you got to notice
your automatic habits and behaviors and
you have to become aware of your
emotions that keep you anchored to the
past and if you can become so conscious
of the one unconscious states of mind
and body that they would never slip by
your conscious awareness again you're
becoming familiar with the old self so
you don't return then if you begin to
think about new ways of being being
defined by a vision
plan your behaviors review them in your
mind now if you keep doing that over and
over again nerve cells that fire
together wire together you begin to
become familiar with a new state of mind
at the same time if you can emotionally
cultivate your inspiration your joy Your
Enthusiasm ahead of the experience by
repeating that over and over again
cultivating that state it's going to
begin to become familiar to you so then
the process of change then requires
unlearning and relearning breaking the
habit of the old self Reinventing a new
self
pruning synaptic connections as we say
in neuroscience and sprouting new
connections unmerizing emotions that are
stored in the body then here's the key
reconditioning the body to a new mind
into a new emotion it's literally moving
from your past to your future it's
losing your mind and creating a new one
and so then when you begin to understand
that in the in that process it's going
to feel a little bit unfamiliar
uncomfortable and if you can relax into
that instead of going back to the past
continuously invest in your future
sooner or later it'll begin to become
easier and easier and easier and all of
a sudden when you least expect it
something amazing is going to happen in
your life and when that event begins to
occur you're going to pay attention to
what you did inside of you now to
produce the effect outside of you and
that's called human empowerment and
there isn't a person in the world that's
excluded from this equation if people
are really really believing that their
astrological sign determines their
Destiny then they will look for based on
their perception the correlations that
are equal to their belief system I don't
particularly believe that because I'm
born at a certain time under certain
house that has anything to do with me
creating the life that I want to have
right so
many people will though and because they
do they'll only they'll select like oh I
saw 11 11 on the clock well
well you've seen three 236 on the clock
and 4 18 on the clock but you're looking
for 11 11. well then that's your reality
because that's where your attention is
right so I don't subscribe to that but I
respect that because that person is
going to keep that belief until it no
longer serves them and they're either
going to evolve their belief or they're
not and if they don't so be it but if
they do they're going to realize sooner
or later it's not working for them I
have certain beliefs right now
that I honestly am questioning that I
still think are limited beliefs but in
order for me to change those beliefs I'm
going to have to come out of my resting
state have to step out into the unknown
and really check to see and execute in a
very different way now
to build on that model
then it's going to require one foot
in the Practical world and one foot in
the Mysterious World because I can't
control all the events that happen in my
life but I can certainly make choices
that are going to bring me closer to
those experiences now I also know from
experience that when I'm living by the
hormones of stress and I'm living in
survival that you and I and everybody
else is always going to try to control
the outcome to try to force the outcome
to try to get in the way try to analyze
when it's going to happen and how it's
going to happen now when that occurs
we're really bad
we're competitive we're manipulative
we'll hold on to things we're deceitful
we're greedy because what those
chemicals do so we're always trying to
control and force the outcome because in
a sense we feel separate from something
greater we feel like we're matter trying
to change matter we feel like uh we're
we're vibrating at the same speed as
everything else and so we have to get
what we want means we have to go and get
it and and and so then people start
mixing spiritual principles with that
phenomenon right so then
that's not what I'm talking about
because I'm talking about
if you're able
to understand that when you're living by
the hormones of stress that your senses
are heightened
and that your materialist trying to
Define reality if you can't see it feel
a taste it smell it doesn't exist and
you're getting ready for something bad
to happen and be prepared and protect
yourself and that's how most people live
then everybody's doing that everybody's
mad at trying to change matter and soon
we're going to bump into each other and
there's going to be Sparks right so then
is it possible then
that instead of being defined as a body
living in an environment in a particular
time
that if you were to close your eyes and
disconnect from the external environment
to sit your body down
into transcend time
and to become nobody
you have the biological Machinery to do
this to become no one you're not a face
you're not a man you're not a
documentary filmmaker
you're not your past you're not your
future you're not a husband
you're not your body you're not your
emotions you're not your habits you're
not the predictable future of the
familiar past
your pure consciousness
now if you are going to heal your body
by thought alone
if you are going to create some event in
your external environment by thought
alone and if you are going to transcend
Time by thought alone then you have to
become thought alone
and so when people start to really
realize that they can change the
neurosircuitry in their brain by thought
alone send new emotional signals that
begin to select and up regulate new
genes and down regulate other genes and
it may take knocking on that door
for extended periods of time to finally
the gene is programmed because it took
them 10 years to program the gene for
the disease it may take them a few years
to reprogram the gene
now we're talking about pragmatist we're
talking about someone who's applying
some principles and so then when that
occurs
and the energy that was sitting in these
hormonal centers of survival of anger
and fear and guilt and shame the energy
kind of moves up a little bit we've
measured This Heart starts to open gets
more coherent the field around the body
begins to grow we've measured that the
person feels more like energy less like
matter they feel like more like wave
less like particles they're not afraid
of the unknown they let's go ahead and
answer that really quick he said like
the greatest part right now
you said knocking on the door I was like
Yeah ironic
oh thank you
all right hopefully you didn't lose your
train of thought so
they're not afraid of the unknown
they're craving them they're trusting in
the unknown
and that that kind of expanded energy
is now they're no longer
enslaved emotionally to the Past they're
no longer an identity that's connected
to a disease they're no longer a body
who's addicted to an emotion they're no
longer trying to forecast the future
based on the past they're no longer a
man they're no longer a woman they're no
longer a nurse they're no longer black
they're no longer white they're no
longer anything they're they're a they
are completely poised in the present
moment and that that that present moment
produces a liberation of energy because
the body is no longer
held to the chains of the past and that
liberation of energy then begins to
produce a biological transformation in
the brain and the body we've seen it the
brain gets highly coherent yet super
organized the person feels whole
we've measured that their heart moves
into a state of joy and and love and
gratitude we measured that the field
around our bodies and hands we measure
that and the person could no longer
cares about the future of the past
they're happy in the present moment they
no longer want anything because they're
whole
and if you're whole it's impossible to
want and that's the moment it happens
and so kind of this Paradox that begins
to occur so why am I explaining it like
this because I want to answer the
ultimate question of what you're asking
is that there's an intelligence that's
giving us life
it's keeping my heart beating and
digesting my food and food and
organizing trillions of functions per
second in every cell of my body I'm not
doing that I'm having a conversation
with you as a free-willed subject of
consciousness
but there is an intelligence within me
that's always endorsing who I'm being
and that intelligence is a Giver of Life
so to demystify it then
and this is where
i s i part from the spiritual community
because when your will
matches its will
when your mind matches its mind when
your love for Life matches its love for
life it begins to work in ways that are
mysterious now
why is that important because the
mysterious is the unknown and the
unknown is unexpected and the unexpected
should bring a surprise and that
surprise should be outside of my current
beliefs if it's happening how could I
expect the supernatural to happen if I'm
expecting it to happen
it's impossible but if I'm in the
unknown and I'm open
to possibility then I should be able to
create an unknown experience that I
can't predict the emotion or the future
event of how it's going to occur when
it's going to occur it's not my job and
the side effect of that is this
mysterious surprise that changes my
biology from the new experience and then
causes me to change my beliefs and I've
I've had enough of my own mystical
moments in the midst of that mystical
experience I have said in the midst of
it I have this all wrong I have said it
right in the midst of the experiment I
am doing this so wrong because I was so
programmed into this box of belief
but the only way the unexpected could
happen is giving up expectation which
means you have to surrender that belief
how it's going to happen or when it's
going to happen I can't predict that so
then that same intelligence that's
giving me life according to the quantum
model of reality is the same
intelligence that's creating supernovas
and causing flowers to bloom it's it's
within us and all around us it's it's a
very wave of quantum physics I can't
control that I can't expect how the
particle is going to appear or when it's
going to appear but it's not my job
my job is to move into different states
of being and be open to the mystery of
how it's going to happen so
if I said to you today Ben that I had
all the answers
to everything I would I would certainly
be limiting this conversation but I am
open to the to the mystery of life and
the Mystery of Life then means that if
we're asking certain questions
and we believe we we even speculate that
it's possible and someone has to step
out into out of their present beliefs to
see if it is
and so I'm not interested in the natural
I'm not interested in the normal
I'm interested in the Supernatural the
supernormal and I believe from my
present state of ignorance of course if
we're going to use the word belief
that you don't have to be a Buddhist
monk
you don't have to be a nun with 40 Years
of devotion you don't have to be a
religious scholar you don't have to be a
researcher you don't have to have a PhD
to do this
that common people around the world can
do the uncommon and if they're given the
right understanding
and the environment is set up where they
can begin the application of that
and I have looked at over a thousand
brain scans of people in meditation
and I can tell you that you and I are at
our absolute best when we get beyond our
analytical mind when we get Beyond
ourselves that's the moment that the
brain gets so organized and so coherent
the front of the brain is talking to the
back of the brain the right side of the
brain is talking the left side of the
brain there's this synchronization this
psychic Union going on a flow and the
person has tears of joy rolling down
their face that Gestalt moment
that that
Transcendent event for the person is
completely subjective but my interest is
measuring that subjective experience and
we're capturing amplitudes of energy in
people's brains that are 26 000 to 40
000 times normal during that experience
now
they can't make their brain do that
it's happening to them and the inner
event that's happening to them is more
real than any past event and that's the
moment I know their belief is changing
can you teach your body emotionally
what the future reality that you want to
live in feels like before it happens now
this is very difficult if you've been
conditioned into believing something in
your outer world has to change to make a
way take away the emptiness or the lack
to make you feel differently this is
saying actually feel the emotion before
it happens and don't wait for the
experience to occur teach your body what
the feeling will be before it occurs if
the environment signals the Gene and the
end product of an experience in the
environment is an emotion you're
signaling the gene ahead of the
environment and genes make proteins and
proteins are responsible for the
structure and function of your body and
the expression of proteins is the
expression of life so teach the body
emotionally to self-regulate to believe
it's living in an environment that's
flourishing that's wonderful keep
practicing it and it'll become familiar
to you and the process then
creates a new identity and it's not
difficult once you understand what
you're doing and why you're doing it and
the more you combine all those different
branches of science and make it in a
simple way to understand if people
understand the what and the why the how
gets easier because you can assign
meaning to what you're doing and it
becomes instrumental so get a group of
people a thousand people 1500 people 2
000 people into a room
teach them that information whether
they're coming for wealth or health a
relationship a new career a mystical
experience get them all together
and teach them and measure what can take
place in one week period of time and I
assure you that's more than 75 percent
of the people that go through and go all
in and Retreat from their lives and
remove the same stimulation from their
environment and not be in the same
conditions and teach them that
information and give them numerous
opportunities to apply it and numerous
opportunities to get Beyond themselves
all you need is that first person that
stands on the stage and says hey I
walked in here with Parkinson's disease
I have no idea what happened but I'm not
trembling anymore and boy that last
thing just something clicked for me and
the person in the audience is watching
the four minute mile right in front of
them and going wow that guy looks like
he's not a vegan he doesn't look like
he's particularly in shape but his
Parkinson's went away and wow I mean if
he could do it I could do it and
somebody else changes their belief and
now that's a footprint and Consciousness
get enough people doing that
by the end of the week you're going to
see things we've seen blind people
seeing deaf people hearing that once not
twice people with Strokes for 10 years
lift their arms up again we've seen
people step out of wheelchairs people on
crutches drop their cracks I mean you
see
the body literally recalibrates to a new
mind and and they're not intentionally
trying to do anything they're just
becoming somebody else but the process
of overcoming
is the process of becoming and if you
teach people that formula and you get
just one or two people doing it it's
just going to become an infection and
it's gonna Wellness is gonna spread just
like disease I think it's a time in
history where it's not enough to know
it's a time in history to know how
and if you think about it um
most people live their life in a habit
they think the same thoughts they
perform the same actions they live by
the same emotions but they secretly
expect their life to change
but how you think how you act and how
you feel is called your personality and
your personality creates your personal
reality that's it so if you think sixty
to seventy thousand thoughts in one day
and ninety percent of those thoughts are
the same thoughts as the day before the
same thoughts always lead to the same
choices the same choices always lead to
the same behaviors the same behaviors
create the same experiences and the same
experiences produce the same emotions
and those same emotions then drive your
very same thoughts and so you get caught
in this kind of biological neurological
and Quantum fixated pattern so then the
hardest part about change really in
creating the life that you want being
defined by a vision of the future
instead of a memory of the past is not
making the same choices you did the day
before and the moment you do that you
step into the unknown now you and I have
been conditioned and hypnotized into
believing
at the unknown in some scary place but
when you begin to realize the unknown is
the perfect place to create from that
void of unpredictability that
uncertainty that unfamiliarity is really
the quantum place of uncertainty where
all manifestations come from so when you
and I become comfortable living in that
unknown place I think then that we begin
to manifest the things we want in our
lives so for me personally
I want to execute and be defined by a
vision of the future instead of the
memories of the past so most people's
brains are organized to reflect
everything they know in their life their
brain is a record of the past and if you
feel the same way every single day and
feelings and emotions are the end
product of past experiences it means
number one nothing new is happening in
your life and number two those emotions
are keeping you anchored to the past if
thoughts are the language of the brain
and feelings are the language of the
body and how you think and how you feel
creates a state of being most people are
literally biologically neurologically
chemically genetically and even Quantum
wise connected to a past so then the
question is the fundamental question is
can you believe in a future that you
can't see or experience with your senses
yet but you've thought about enough
times in your mind that your brain has
literally changed to look like the
experience has already occurred now the
latest research in neuroscience and
neuroplasticity tells us we can change
our brain to look like the event has
already occurred and can we begin to
emotionally Embrace a future reality
that's a potential in the quantum field
and begin to emotionally embrace it to
such agree that we fall in love with
that future reality that our bodies Our
unconscious mind begins to believe it's
living in that future reality in the
present moment and we're signaling new
genes and new ways to change our body to
look like the experience has already
occurred in preparation for the event
now think about this so making our inner
World more real than the outer world
right but not only that
you have to then understand that when
you truly do this properly you're not
waiting for your healing to feel whole
you're not waiting for your success to
feel empowered you're not waiting for
your wealth to feel abundant you're not
waiting for your new relationship to
feel love you're not waiting for the
mystical moment to feel awe that's the
old model of reality of cause and effect
waiting for something outside of you to
change how you feel inside of you and
when you feel better inside and you pay
attention to whoever whatever caused
that that's that's cause and effect and
when you begin to make the correlation
between what changed you from outside
and inside you create an associate of
memory
the quantum model of reality begins to
say then you have to teach your body
emotionally how that future is going to
feel like before it's made manifest in
other words you have to feel awe in
order for the mystical moment to happen
you have to feel a abundance before your
wealth can occur you have to feel in
love with life before your new
relationship happens and so we're not
defining Reality by our senses because
we're not waiting then for anything
outside of us to change how we feel
inside of us so if there's physical
evidence in your brain and body to look
like the experience has already occurred
physical evidence
because the epigenetic model of reality
says you can change your body by thought
alone you and neuroplasticity says you
can change your brain by thought alone
so if there's physical evidence to look
like the experience has already occurred
well relax because the experience is
going to find you and it's going to come
in a way that you least expect the
survival emotions the emotions that are
derived from the hormones of stress are
very addictive
anger is addictive fear is addictive
sadness is addictive resentment is
addictive competition is addictive
frustration is addictive all of those
emotions that are derived from the
hormones of stress give the brain and
body A Rush of energy so if an addiction
is something you can't stop and you
happen to have a friend or a family
member who's walking around suffering
every single day of their life and you
say to them why don't you stop or you
you're in the middle of an angry
experience and I say to you Michael why
don't you just stop being angry if you
can't stop
you can't stop that that on some level
you're addicted because an addiction is
something you can't stop so when people
start to understand oh my God I'm
addicted to my own frustration I'm
addicted to my own suffering I'm
addicted to my own guilt all of a sudden
they start becoming conscious of what
they're doing to their brain and body
show them how those very chemicals down
regulate genes to create disease
and then get them beyond that by doing
meditation that's the moment then all of
a sudden they begin to be greater than
their biology and we've measured this
thousands of times in people and it's
without a doubt I can say this from
every single cell in my being that a
person is at their absolute best when
they get Beyond themselves that's the
bottom line seventy percent of the time
people live in by the hormones are
stress whether they know it or not
they're always anticipating the future
based on the past they're always having
their attention on objects and people
and things and places in the world
because that's where the danger is the
chemicals are jacking up their body so
their attention is on their body so they
think based on their own experience that
they're their body but they're not they
believe that they're their identity
that's connected to relationships of
people and things and places in their
life but they're not then when people
start to live on autopilot and they get
out of bed the same way and they brush
their teeth at the same hand and they do
all the same things every single day and
they've been doing that for 20 or 30
years for the most part then their
body's on autopilot it's in a
predictable future based on what it's
done in the past so very few people are
in the present moment so then they're
locked into a line of time a linear line
of time where their future and their
past seem to be exactly the same so no
not a lot of people are present or in
the present moment and if you're not in
the present moment I assert that you're
running some type of program which means
you're not present the body's already
programmed to be in the future in the
past so then
in an elegant moment of meditation and
we've we can predict this now on a brain
scam there comes a moment where a person
forgets about their body
they forget they're they're so involved
in their inner world that there is
nobody
they forget that they are an identity
they're not paying attention to the
people they know and the places they go
and the things they have to do or the
things they own they become no one they
become no thing they go to nowhere and
they forget about their appointments in
their past and they become no time and
that is the moment they become pure
Consciousness that is the moment that
they begin to disconnect from their
biology and who you are to answer that
question is a Consciousness that's
manipulating the brain and body to
produce different levels of mind
and only when you are pure consciousness
can you begin to change your body only
when you are beyond your body can you
heal your body you can't the body can't
heal the body you have to get beyond
your body to heal your body in order for
you to create some new experience in
your life you got to get beyond the
problems in your life in order for you
to create some new future event in some
future time you got to get Beyond
predictable linear time and so if you're
going to heal your body by thought alone
if you're going to create some
experience in your life by thought alone
if you are going to create some new
event in your future by thought alone
then you have to become thought alone
and that is the moment when you become
pure Consciousness where you are nobody
no one no thing nowhere in no time that
is the moment
that you're no longer constrained by
those laws that is the moment your
Consciousness freewilled subjective
human consciousness merges with the
quantum field the objective Universal
Consciousness and when they come
together and you come back to awareness
you take a piece of it with you and you
become more like it you become more
willful it has an amazing will you
become more mindful it has an infinite
mind become more conscious it has a
great Consciousness you become more
loving it's a it's a love it's a lover
of life you become more Giver giving
it's a giver of life it's it's nature
becomes your nature and so teaching
people how to do that uh is the art so
then when you understand that you we we
we we now know that there are certain
ways to do that that help people get
there faster according to the
psychological and scientific model
the majority of people in their waking
day in a normal day spend about 70
percent of their time living in stress
and living in stress is living in
survival
and the actual definition of stress
stress is when your body's knocked out
of homeostasis
stress is when your body's not that of
balance
the stress response is what your body
innately does to return itself back to
order you have three types of stress you
have physical stress like trauma
injuries accidents Falls you have
chemical stress like bacteria viruses
blood sugar levels heavy metals and food
hangovers whatever
and you have emotional stress like
traffic jams internet connections second
mortgages single parenting 401ks family
tragedies all of those things knock the
brain and body out of balance
now all organisms in nature can adapt to
short-term stress
pack of coyotes chases a deer in the in
the forest the deer outruns the coyotes
the stress is over the theory turns back
to homeostasis and it grazes again the
event is over when the deer perceives a
threat in its external environment it
turns on a primitive nervous system
called the fight-or-flight nervous
system
and that autonomic nervous system that
sympathetic nervous system begins to
mobilize enormous amounts of energy for
some threat in the external environment
now
the year has all its physiology changed
all the blood is sent to the extremities
heart rate increases respiratory rate
rate increases pupils dilate dilate the
1300 chemicals that are created in a
matter of seconds is to cause the deer
to survive in some difficult condition
now
human beings have the same mechanisms
and when we perceive a threat in our
external environment like a lion we are
going to run or fight or freeze
but if you've had problems with your
co-worker
or you've had a very difficult
experience with your mother-in-law
the moment you perceive your
mother-in-law or your co-worker you and
you have a past experience with them
you're going to turn on the same
primitive nervous system
just like you were being chased by a
lion so what was once highly adaptive
now becomes very maladaptive because
when you're mobilizing all of that
energy
you are going to operate in very
predictable ways you're going to be an
amped up animal with a big memory bank
so that your blood flow is going to go
to the hind brain and away from the
forebrain which means you're going to
react instead of think
rationalize
but human beings the privilege of being
a human being is that we can make
thought more real than anything else
that's the privilege
so then you can begin to forecast
some future worst case scenario
and you can attend to that thought to
the exclusion of everything else
and you can focus on it to such a degree
that you will begin to anticipate the
event and produce the same chemicals as
if you're in that experience and you're
knocking your brain and body out of
balance just by thought alone
you can begin to unfold some past bitter
memory that's tattooed in the recesses
of your gray matter and like magic you
can bring it to life and in that moment
it's real and you will produce the same
chemistry in your brain and body as if
that event occurred and your body is the
unconscious mind is literally living
that experience
so then when we're living by the
hormones of stress and you turn on that
stress response and you can't turn it
off now you're headed for some disease
because no organism in nature can
tolerate living in emergency mode for
extended periods of time so if 70 of the
time a person's living in survival
living in stress in survival what we do
in order to survive
as we are going to select the worst case
scenario
and we are going to begin to plan our
behaviors and our emotions in that
experience because anything less than
the worst case scenario means we have
better chances of survival so we plan
for the worst we emotionally embrace it
and anything less means we can survive
so out of the infinite Potentials in the
quantum field
anxiety really represents a poor
imagination but it's highly adaptive if
it's if you're living in survival
because you got to get ready for that so
70 of the time people are selecting the
worst case event in their life and
emotionally embracing it and they're
they're programming their autonomic
nervous system into a very specific
Destiny and turns out if you keep doing
that and you create the emotions of fear
and worry and anxiety
and you do that for 10 years or five
years or three years your body is going
to unconsciously become programmed to
fear and it's going to have a panic
attack without you try as you may with
your conscious mind to control it you've
programmed it subconsciously and now the
body as the mind is running the show
so
the hormones of stress
create the emotions of anger
of aggression of hostility of violence
of frustration of hatred of fear of
anxiety of guilt of Shame of
hopelessness of powerlessness depression
those are all chemicals that are derived
from the hormones of stress and when we
live by the hormones of stress we become
very selfish why because when you're in
survival you've got to take care of the
self your tension is on your body right
your attention is on your external
environment there's Predators out there
the the rush of adrenaline causes the
senses to become heightened and you're a
materialist and you're trying to predict
the future because there's better
chances of survival if you can predict
the future based on the past when that
occurs then over time
the body begins to break down because
it's a scientific fact
that the hormones of stress down
regulate genes to create disease in the
long term
so if you can turn on the stress
response just by thought alone
and the hormones of stress can make you
sick
then your thoughts can literally make
you sick so the question is if your
thoughts can make you sick
is it possible then that your thoughts
can make you well your personality
creates your personal reality
that's it
and your personality is made up of how
you think
how you act
and how you feel
so the present personality who's
listening to this podcast has created
the present personal reality called
their life
so if you believe what I just said then
in order for you to create a new
personal reality a new life you're gonna
have to change your personality in other
words nothing changes in your life until
you change that's the way it is so turns
out the 90 of the thoughts that we think
on a daily basis are the same thoughts
as the day before
same thoughts lead to the same choices
same choices lead to the same behaviors
same behaviors create the same
experiences the same experiences produce
the same feelings and the same emotions
and those same feelings and emotions
begin to influence our very same
thoughts and our biology
our neural circuitry our neural
chemistry are hormones are gene
expression our immune system
all stay the same because we're staying
the same so then there's a principle in
Neuroscience that says that nerve cells
that fire together wire together you
keep thinking the same thoughts they
keep making the same choices you keep
doing the same things you keep creating
the same experiences that stamp the same
networks of neurons into the same exact
patterns all for the reaffirming of the
same feeling and you do that for 10
years on end
the firing and wiring of those
circuitries begins to hardwire the brain
into a very finite signature that box in
the brain that's created is the same
level of mind and if you keep doing that
it becomes automatic
it turns out that 95 of Who We Are by
the time we're in the middle of our life
is a set of memorized behaviors
automatic emotional reactions constant
habits hardwired attitudes beliefs
perceptions
that have happened just because we've
we've just fired and wired it the same
way so there's a good possibility then
in order for us to change we better
start thinking about what we've been
thinking about and changing we have to
become conscious of our unconscious
habits and behaviors and modify them we
got to look at these feelings that we
feel every single day instead of just
thinking it's a feeling say what is this
is this guilt is this sadness is this
unhappiness is this pain is it
frustration is it resentment what is the
feeling that I'm living by the majority
of my day now
that's lighting a match in a dark place
and Neuroscience is called metacognition
the word meditation means to become
familiar with that's what it means
so the more familiar with you are I
can't with I can't it's too hard I'm
never going to change it's my ex's fault
it's my boss's fault it's my country's
fault it's the government it's the
weather it's my pain whatever that
thought is that you accept believe and
surrender to on a daily basis that's
automatic
you have to become so conscious of that
unconscious thought
that it doesn't slip by your awareness
unnoticed you got to catch yourself
saying I'm tired I'm unhappy that
someone else's fault do you complain do
you blame do you make excuses do you
feel sorry for yourself that that
personality
has to change in order to create a new
life so then you have to become so aware
of your unconscious habits that you
don't go unconscious to them in your
waking day then you got to sit in the
fire of those emotions
and you gotta watch those emotions come
up and you have to sit with them and
know that there's something on the other
side of them now this is where most
people get up and say I can't meditate
or I'm going to call up my friend or I'm
gonna get on social media and make a
post I'm gonna turn on the football game
I'm gonna get distracted because I need
something out there to make this go away
and what we're saying is we're not
relying on anything out there that's the
that's the hypnosis that's the
conditioning we want you to just become
so familiar with that feeling that you
catch yourself in your waking day the
moment you start
feeling sad and your energy drops ah you
catch yourself so
there's an unlearning process
or breaking the habit of being the old
self process that requires
a lot of attention
a lot of awareness and it takes energy
you gotta stay conscious worry sadness
pain when we do that unconsciously
that's what a program is
and that becomes the habit
so if you're living in a world where men
have to provide and show a certain
amount of success and be competitive
then you're not going to open your heart
it's not a time to do that it's a time
to survive and thrive in an environment
and yet
um in our work I see men that if they
practice
yeah opening their hearts and it's just
being a child again being a boy again
being curious being wondering being free
being allowing yourself to let go
and for men we have to lay down the very
thing we used our whole life to get what
we want for something greater to occur
now the side effect of that when men
truly do this I've seen them
instantaneously heal from things from
serious heart conditions where they
couldn't take more than 40 steps without
having an angina reaction
uh severe chest pain to stage four
cancer the House of Cards when it falls
energy moves into a different place and
the body begins to release 13 or 1400
different chemicals that begin to
restore and repair the body so to the
intellectual mind
if a man begins to understand that when
they open their heart they could heal
when they open their heart they can lead
from a different Consciousness that it's
actually
an advantage and they understand the
science of why in their rational mind
then they go after it now they're in Hot
Pursuit of it because it makes sense to
them but there's not a lot of
evidence or support in our environment
for men to be vulnerable and yet the
latest research shows that vulnerability
is one of the five top qualities for a
great leader so when men begin to think
this through
they start to slowly by slowly just like
a flower blooming pedal by petal they
start trusting a little bit more they
start opening up a little bit more they
start getting happier they start
breaking down the wall the facade that
they they've created to have an
appearance
of being a certain way for the world and
yet feeling so empty inside of them they
start realizing
that that the joy that they want never
came from success never came from wealth
or his popularity or whatever men do but
it really comes from within so
we give them numerous opportunities to
practice
numerous opportunities to connect I
travel around the world and I have the
opportunity to talk to all kinds of
people and one of the things that
independent of people's beliefs
political beliefs religious beliefs
whatever there seems to be a Common
Thread that people feel like something's
not right
and I think when
um you get to a point where you realize
that no health care plan no government
no religion is going to take care of you
then who is going to take care of you
and the answer is you right
so my interest is to give people the
tools and the understanding that they
could heal their body that they could
create a better life for themselves
that they could overcome past traumas
and scars that were created even as
early as childhood that tend to be
unconscious programs that keep them
repeating the same you know scenarios in
their life
to teach people how to induce mystical
experiences so that it changes the frame
of what the way they look at reality
and so what an amazing time in history
to be alive because Consciousness is
awareness
and awareness is paying attention and
paying attention is noticing so so if a
person lives a life as an example
and is diagnosed with a health condition
they're what they're conscious of
is just a certain number of choices that
they could make based on the past based
on tradition based on what's worked for
normal or natural
but what happens when that person has
done the chemotherapy has done the
surgery has done the radiation has done
the vegan diet has done the gluten-free
diet has done the ketogenic diet has
done all the things all the exercise
and they still have the same health
condition
yeah it begs the question
if our personality creates our personal
reality
and our personality is made up of how we
think how we act and how we feel
then the present personality who's
listening to this podcast has created
the present personal reality called
their life not their ex not their
parents not their culture they create
their life
so the fundamental question is if if
I want to change my life
then that means that I have to change or
nothing changes in my life until I
change right so the person who's done
all these treatments and still faced
with a health condition this is just an
example
all of a sudden says there's got to be
another way there's got to be something
else and so knowledge information
when we learn knowledge when we learn
information we make new Connections in
our brain that's what learning is we're
forging synaptic connections
but that philosophical theoretical
intellectual information is void of
experience
someone who takes that knowledge and
applies it and personalizes demonstrates
it initiates that knowledge
is now interested in the truth of the
experience of that information
so the person then who becomes conscious
that they could actually heal themselves
by changing the way they think the way
they act the way they feel if I truly go
into the experiment of no longer
thinking the same way no longer acting
the same way no longer feeling the same
way and I start thinking about what
thoughts I do want to fire and wire in
my brain
and if I do it with intention and
attention I'll begin to install
neurological Hardware keep doing it and
becomes like a software program it
becomes a new voice in your head it goes
from I can't to I can
no magic there if you said how would
greatness live today how what would love
look like today what would be a greater
expression of myself in the things that
I do
turns out if you close your eyes and you
rehearse in your mind
how you're going to be
in any aspect of your day if you're
truly present the brain doesn't know the
difference between the inward experience
of what you're imagining and the outer
real experience and look the brain looks
like you've already done it the brain
looks like it's already experiencing now
do that enough times the hardware
becomes a software program and you start
behaving like a different person super
athletes do this this is musicians
athletes dancers everybody who's good at
something is always rehearsing in their
mind
that that rehearsal is just as important
as the physical demonstration it's
priming the brain because the brain is a
record of the past now you're actually
making it a map to the Future you're
installing circuits to use
if you said God I live my whole life in
guilt I didn't know it was guilt uh in
shame or unworthiness unself-doubt and
security fear and all of a sudden you're
looking at that emotion you understand
that emotion is actually down regulating
genes and creating disease you figured
that out you read about it makes sense
then all of the hatred all the anger all
the bitterness you have to someone or
something in your past
is keeping you connected to the past so
you'd say
can I teach my body emotionally what a
new future could feel like before it
happens not waiting for your wealth to
feel abundance or waiting for your
relationship to feel love or waiting for
your healing to feel gratitude that's
the old model of reality of cause and
effect this is about causing an effect
turns out if you can elevate your
emotional state
and you can sustain that emotional state
your body's so objective that it doesn't
know the difference between the real
life experience that's creating that
emotion
and that emotion that you're creating by
thought alone your body's actually
believing it's living in a new reality
in new environments now the environment
signals the gene the end product of an
experience in the environment is an
emotion that person is actually
signaling genes ahead of the environment
genes make proteins and proteins are
responsible for the structure and
function of the body the expression of
proteins is the expression of life okay
every day the person practices going
from the old self to the new cell this
is what's happening in the world right
now
as they start to change and they start
unfiring and unwiring and they stop
conditioning the body emotionally for
the past and practice this
they emerge as a new personality they
become somebody else and like magic the
disease exists in the old person
and there's somebody else now here's
where Consciousness comes in
that person comes to a workshop and they
stand on the stage in front of 1500
people and they tell their story
and everybody in that audience is
leaning in
why because they're looking at truth
they're looking at the someone who just
got healed from a chronic uh chronic
because I'm talking about stage four
cancers I'm talking about Parkinson's
disease I'm talking about rare genetic
disorders
and now the person in the audience is
becoming conscious
of a possibility that they were once
unconscious to And when they see that's
possible it's a four minute mile I mean
four minute mile nobody thought anybody
could break a mile and under formulas
they said it was biological artificial
yeah physiologically impossible 1400
people have done it already so like this
is the four minute mile someone's
piercing through a limitation the level
of unconsciousness and now that's a
footprint in the quantum field but in
three-dimensional reality you're looking
at that person they look no different
than anybody else and the person says
if that person can do it I think there's
this feeling
um that we all have
that never seems to go away and it's an
intuition it's an instinct that tells us
that there's more to reality than this
dream and and I think that people come
to this work for that feeling
and I think that we're greater than we
think more powerful than we know more
unlimited uh than we could ever dream
and my passion
my interest is to take science and
combine quantum physics with
Neuroscience with neuroendocrinology
with
psychoneuroimmunology with uh the
epigenetics electromagnetism and I think
science is that language to demystify
the mystical
and to build models of understanding
from a theoretical and intellectual
knowledge-based analytical perspective
but
that knowledge void of experience is
philosophy but if you can teach people
how to practically apply it to to
personalize it to demonstrate it to
initiate that knowledge
and do something with it
if they can get their behaviors to match
their intentions or their actions equal
to their thoughts if they get their mind
and body working together they're going
to have an experience right and it turns
out that learning information makes
Connections in the brain but experience
enriches those connections well the
moment those neurons string into place
there's a biological change that takes
place in the brain another part of the
brain makes a chemical and that chemical
is called an emotion and the moment you
feel successful the moment you feel
empowered the moment you feel Unlimited
I think now you're teaching your body
chemically to understand what your mind
is intellectually understood so
knowledge is for the mind and
experiences for the body and so what we
learned in this whole process of
transformation is that the more people
understand what they're doing
and why they're doing it the how gets
easier so when the experience then is
causes them to embody the truth of that
philosophy it's no longer theoretical
it's experiential and it's visceral so
the experience then
produces a strong emotion and the
emotion then is what is the information
coming uh back to the body that begins
to select and instruct new genes and
we've measured this on people that they
could actually change their gene
expression in in three or four days by
doing this now if you've done it once
it means you got to be able to do it
again right so anybody who's serious
about their own personal growth and
evolution
the replication of any experience will
begin to both neurologically and
chemically condition the mind and body
to work as one so when you've done
something so many times that your body
now knows how to do it better than your
conscious mind now it's innating you
it's implicit it's automatic it's second
nature it's easy you've become the
knowledge and in a sense you've mastered
that knowledge and you're in a new state
of being so
my interest is demystify that process so
that people have within their reach all
the tools begin to apply it to their
lives the hardest part about change is
not making the same Choice as you did
the day before
when you decide to make a different
Choice whether it's to change something
that you eat or exercise or to no longer
react to certain people or conditions in
your life remember you're going to feel
uncomfortable now that's not a bad thing
that's actually a good thing that means
you're in the unknown and when you step
into the unknown you're going through
dramatic changes in your own personal
biology
when you're in that place of uncertainty
that place of unpredictability that void
that unknown ask yourself what thoughts
do you want to believe in and fire and
wire in your brain what behaviors would
you like to demonstrate that's equal to
a vision of the future close your eyes
and rehearse them review every step no
different than an athlete beginning to
rehearse what they're about to do the
act of rehearsing it begins to prime
your brain to prepare you for that
behavior in your future and then finally
can you teach your body emotionally what
that future is going to feel like before
it happens and when you begin to fall
into the present moment and marry those
intentions with an elevated emotion your
body is believing it's living in that
future reality in the present moment and
you're changing your biology from living
in your past present reality to living
in your future present reality and your
job then is to be able to maintain that
modified State of Mind and Body your
entire day and if you can get ready
because something unusual is going to
happen in your life it's the law we may
not be able to control everything in our
outer world but we certainly can control
our inner world and so it's not so
important to not react I mean everybody
reacts I react the question is how long
are you going to react so if you keep an
emotional reaction going on for an
extended period of time you're
memorizing that emotion and your body is
the unconscious mind is believing it's
living in the same past experience 24
hours a day seven days a week 365 days a
year the body doesn't know the
difference between the real experience
that produces the emotion and emotion
that we create by thought alone so then
the emotion then reaffirms the state and
then people start to use the problems
and the conditions in their life to keep
that emotion going and I would call that
an addiction so we become addicted to
the very life we don't even like so
it's important then for people to
realize then when you have that moment
where you have crisis or something
breaks down that you do have control
over it and it's a formula and it's a
skill and our research shows that you
can teach people how to do that and so
then when you're living by some emotion
there'll always be a gap between the way
things appear and the way things really
are emotions alter our perception and if
you act during that time you'll always
say the same thing I should have never
said that I should have never done that
I should never thought that I should
have never sent that email so then
shortening your emotional reactions
is a level of intelligence then that
causes you then to recalibrate because
most people don't think they have
control over that they'll say that
person did it to me that circumstance is
the reason I am this way then I would
say if something in your outer
environment
is controlling your thoughts and
feelings then you're a victim to your
environment and yet
how you think and feel creates your
outer world so if you're thinking and
feeling equal to everything that's known
in your present personal reality you
keep creating more of the same so to
change then is to think and feel greater
than the conditions in your environment
and be able to do that to such a degree
then you're no longer reacting to the
same people in the same way and that
takes an effort it's and it's not easy
in the beginning but once you start
practicing
uh you get better at it and just like
anything else you start to move through
your life with more coherence and you're
less likely to knee-jerk and if you're
less likely to knee jerk then you're not
in an unconscious program I always tell
my advancing students you know when
you're changing is when you stop talking
about it
because when you are truly changing
you can't go to church and shake hands
and say peace be with you and then get
in your car and cut everybody off on the
way out of the parking lot you can't say
I don't like the war in Iraq and be
arguing with your next door neighbor or
your co-worker you have to be the living
example of everything you want to see in
the world in terms of change if you
don't like greed start giving
you know you have to demonstrate and
when you do you give people permission
to do the same because they're going to
observe you doing exactly what they're
afraid to do but they know it's the
right thing to do so the way we
transform the world as we transform
ourselves
and the way you transform a culture is
you transform an individual an
individual by individual when we stop
looking outside of us and we say that
world is a reflection of some aspect of
me if everybody in the world did that
simultaneously imagine how the world
would change and it's not enough to just
focus on peace yeah there's been great
studies that have shown that when a
community of people focus on peace that
the crime rates drop but when they leave
and the research is over the crime rates
we turn back to the ceiling value it's
not enough to just think you got to
demonstrate it you got to show it in all
areas of your life and when you
demonstrate it now it becomes an example
for people to follow we're all faced
with uh
great challenges brilliantly disguised
as impossible situations and there's
always a door there's always a door
and so
your personality creates your personal
reality it's that simple and your
personality is made up of how you think
how you act and how you feel so the
present personality who's listening to
this show has created the present
personal reality called their life which
means if you're going to change
something in your personal reality
in your life you got to change your
personality you have to change nothing
changes
until you change that's the bottom line
you change but you the thought of
changing my personality seems so like
but I like who I am kind of but I'm also
cranky I'm also annoyed so like who is
that person underneath
all of these ailments I guess all of
these but it's a weird thing to say you
change your personality
well look I mean there's many things
that I love about my personality just
like you do I'm gonna take that with me
but there are things if I'm going to be
defined by a vision of the future
they're things that can't come because
the moment you say I want to have a
mystical experience where I transcend
this three-dimensional world and and you
want to have a really profound moment a
transcendental moment you start showing
up for that and it doesn't happen right
away then what you start disbelieving
you start Stop Believing yourself so so
the moment we're defined by a vision of
the future that's bigger than us that
vision of the future is not the vision
of the past and when we do that we take
away we take with us our discipline we
take our concentration we take our
presence we take our passion we take our
strengths with us all those things you
take but the things that are standing in
the way are those old beliefs are things
that stand in a way that that that that
stop you from connecting to it those are
the things you come up against and and
it's not the it's not the mystical
experience of the transcendental
experience it's who you become it's not
your wealth it's not your health it's
who you become it's not your freedom
it's who you become in the process and
it's the overcoming process that we
overcome that we overcome that we
overcome that we overcome till we
finally become and so many great people
in history you know even wealthy people
people always want to be wealthy but if
you study wealthy people that really did
it they failed miserably thousands of
times until they figured it out and so
you keep showing up for yourself enough
times
you're going to change you're going to
change you're going to be thinking
differently you're going to be acting
differently you're going to be feeling
differently and that's when the universe
starts to conspire in ways that we just
never even thought about that's that's
that's the beauty behind creation when a
person begins to slow their brain waves
down they have to go when you're in
stress when you're in survival you
narrow your focus on a cause that's
called a what's called a convergent
Focus so now you're blessing the energy
centers of the body they're under the
control of the autonomic nervous system
and when the autonomic nervous system
moves out of balance the brain moves out
of balance right we now are focus on the
cause and it causes each one of these
different energy centers
to move into incoherence as well and
those little little individual brains
start moving into in coherence and send
an incoherent message to the cells and
tissues and organs hormones then become
down regulated and the body starts
moving out of balance
so when we bless the energy centers
where we reprogram these energy centers
two things has to happen
they have to be able to slow their brain
waves down they have to get out of that
high beta State and the way we do it is
to go from a narrow Focus to a broad
focus when you open your focus when you
open your awareness that's what creates
coherence in the brain because you're
going against that habit
putting your attention on matter
so there's a convergent Focus which is
focusing on matter and then there's a
Divergent Focus which is focusing on
energy well reality is both particle and
wave matter and energy so if a person
can slow their brain waves down from
beta brain waves to Alpha brain waves
now they're starting to fall out of
their thinking brain right into the home
of the autonomic nervous system okay the
person can change their brain waves
it'll never work because they're in
their neocortex in their thinking mind
right so that's one thing that has to
happen the second thing that has to
happen is that they have to practice
both a convergent focus and a Divergent
Focus now by the convergent you're
focusing on let's say I'm going to focus
on this energy center right and then you
move your focus to another energy well
first you first you focus on that energy
center that's particle and then you
focus on the space around it that's wave
and so when you open your awareness and
you're able to do that and you're in
your autonomic nervous system you can
put an intention there which will create
more balance and estrogen more balance
and your your sexual organs you move to
your second Center you put your
attention there that's your where you
place your attentions where you place
your energy so now you're beginning to
Direct Energy yeah into that Center but
now you become aware of the space around
it why to create coherence and that
little brain send the coherent message
to the cells and tissues go to your
third center right in the pit of your
gut well there's a huge Celiac plexus
there solar plexus a lot of connections
in there so now put your big one that's
a big always getting a lot of signs
there yeah here and here part and solar
pressure yeah that's those are big ones
and you tune into that energy then you
put your attention in your heart it has
its own individual brain yeah and when
you make energy here when energy finally
arrives here guess where it goes
automatically straight up we've measured
it so now once you start opening your
heart you've got more energy in your
heart you get more energy in your brain
got it start on time just go straight to
the heart that's why we do it that's
exactly why we that's why we open the
heart so it creates a field and it
begins to drive energy to the brain so
now that energy is going to cause the
person
to have a different Consciousness a
different thought pattern right and now
they're going to be thinking possibility
because in survival the first three ones
are all about survival yeah it's really
not a creative process of creating from
mind it's more about a more primitive
you know
um
humanistic part of us you know animal
part of us so then there's the thyroid
plexus the pineal gland the pituitary
glands so we've seen when people create
coherence in each one of these energy
centers and they do it properly they
know how to change their brain waves
they get into the operating system they
can Master convergent and Divergent
Focus they're no longer living just this
way they've practiced opening their
awareness and focus on energy becoming
conscious of it and as these brains
become more coherent and they start
producing different signals to hormones
and chemicals and into different glands
in the body that's what's being
upregulated to make different different
Expressions one of my biggest problems
is that I tend to react quickly to
negative situations
how how can I cope with anger do you
have any suggestions or advice
yeah I'll tell you the first thing
it's not that you react we all react
the question is how long are you going
to react that's the question so
we found out that when people react
emotionally with anger with antagonism
uh there's an arousal that takes place
because you're turning on the
sympathetic nervous system and the
sympathetic nervous systems the
Primitive system saying Alex whatever
that whatever that is is a threat to you
and if there's a threat a good way to
deal with a threat is to get aggressive
that's primitive it's animal it's very
animal some people will say oh my God
there's my ex and instead of getting
angry they run
they they they flee they're in fear
they're like the fear is I'm better just
getting away so they they Their Fear
causes them to run uh uh so uh when
people feel fear when they feel anger
when they feel pain those are the
primary stimulators that switch on that
sympathetic nervous system and they used
to say
that it's automatic like it's automatic
it happens automatically that's part of
the autonomic nervous system and you
really don't have any control of it
turns out that's absolutely not the
truth so first thing
is learning how to shorten your response
to the emotional reaction so if you have
an event that happens to your life in in
your life and I say
Alex why are you so mad today and you
say oh it's because of this situation
and this person this happened this way
and I would say oh my gosh all right do
you mean
that that person or that circumstance is
controlling the way you feel and the way
you think now anything that's
controlling the way we feel and the way
we think makes us victims
whatever that is now that's okay but if
you keep that emotional reaction going
on
for hours or days and I say to you Alex
it's five days what's up and you say to
me I'm I'm upset from something that
happened to me five days ago I'd say you
have a mood you're in a mood now some
people
keep that same emotional reaction going
on
for weeks or months and then I would say
well Alex has a angry temperament it
becomes a temperament if we keep it
going for now this is true people keep
this going for years on end
if it goes on for years now it's a
personality trait so here's the weird
part about it
you ask that person who's been angry for
years why they're angry
and they'll recall an event from 10
years ago or a series of events from 10
years ago yeah
and the research on the memory says that
50 of that story isn't even the truth
that they can't even remember the truth
they embellish the story and make it
sound worse than it really was to excuse
themselves from changing now
what we tell people is
forget the event
doesn't matter the details of the event
doesn't what matters
is learning how to overcome the emotion
so when you're sitting in a meditation
and all of a sudden out of nowhere your
body starts getting aroused and it
starts getting frustrated and it starts
getting angry and people say I'm doing
my meditation wrong you know what I say
to them no no no no you're doing it
right because that has to come up so
then
so when the younger and the frustration
comes up and a person's in a meditation
they have one of two choices to quit
which is what they've always done
but if you're sitting with 1500 people
and no one else is quitting you're not
going to quit
and if I teach you how to lower the
volume to that emotion and I teach you a
way to change that
if you have a very brain driven person
like myself
and in some parts I disconnected from my
emotions just to protect me in regular
life
and it's a challenge for me to reconnect
to my old emotions that I already have
in circumstances that would help do you
have any advice
yeah well uh God I have a lot of advice
around that because
um
uh 70 of the time that people in their
waking lives
they live in a very protective State
they live in a state of stress or in a
state of survival in fact it's such a
program that we don't know that we're
doing this we're always
expanding the environment to determine
if it's safe or not and if something
appears out of the predictable or
unknown it alerts us and we move into a
state of arousal and we begin to turn on
the very systems that begin to say
danger threat possible scenario that's
not uh safe
and when that happens we literally begin
to anticipate an outcome and when we do
that we're always preparing
for what could go wrong
and we begin to create the emotions
ahead of the experience of what happens
if it goes wrong whether it's fear
anxiety worry sadness pain when we do
that unconsciously that's what a program
is
and that becomes the habit
so if you're living in a world where men
have to provide and show a certain
amount of success and be competitive
then you're not going to open your heart
it's not a time to do that it's a time
to survive and thrive in an environment
and yet
um in our work I see men that if they
practice
yeah opening their hearts and it's just
being a child again being a boy again
being curious being wondering being free
being allowing yourself to let go
because you made it this far yo I want
to celebrate you most people start and
don't finish most people never actually
follow through most people say they want
something but they don't ever do the
work to actually get it but you're
different you are special believe Nation
you made it here all the way to the end
and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to learn
how to attract more things into your
life check the video right there next to
me I think you'll love it continue to
believe and I'll see you there I think
we've been programmed quite a bit with
our relationship with money I mean we
have a relationship with everything
known in our environment you have a
relationship a neurological Network in
your brain for your parents for your
cell phone